und wir schauen auf den nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt denn jetzt geht es
weiter mit der haushaltswoche bzw mit
einzeletats des Bundeskabinetts der
Bundesministerium
Einzelplan 07 steht auf der Tagesordnung
sowie der Einzelplan 19 und da geht es
um den Etat des bundesjustizministers
das
Bundesjustizministeriums und des
Bundesverfassungsgericht das wird immer
in einem Schwung mit diskutiert und
jetzt werden wir einen Blick auf die
Liste der Redner frei ist
die erste Rednerin sein wenn die Liste
hier stimmt aus der Unionsfraktion
sie ist Beisitzerin im Bundesvorstand
und
Ausschuss im Ausschuss für digitales
auch das spielt jetzt hier bei diesem
Thema nicht die entscheidende Rolle
Empfehlung des Haushaltsausschusses aber
sie war auch mit im Team von Norbert
Röttgen als es um die
Wahl des CDU-Vorsitzenden gegen da hätte
sie wenn ich mich richtig erinnere gute
Chancen gab Generalsekretärin zu werden
sowas zumindest geplant die Wahl ist
bekanntermaßen anders ausgegangen
jedenfalls
ist eine Dauer von 90 wer jetzt den
Punkt dass die Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
Marc was die Aussprache eröffnet wie ein
Mann noch mal die Abgeordneten in den
hinteren Reihen die hier stehen und ein
Schwätzchen halten das ist nicht Usus
und auch nicht angenehm für die die
vorne am Puls stehen weil das natürlich
eine gewisse Unruhe verursacht so die
sind jetzt mehr oder weniger
rausgeschickt worden und das ganze auch
mehr oder weniger deutlich von der
Bundestags viel Präsidentin so dass
jetzt der Rede von Franziska Oppermann
nichts weiter im Weg steht und da ist
sie auch schon so gut wie am Punkt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Zuschauer
auf den Tribünen und sehr geehrter Herr
Minister wir kommen in dieser Debatte
nun zum Haushalt des Justizministeriums
oder wie es auch heißt das
gesetzgebungsministeriums fast alle
Redner zum Einzelplan justizbetonen
immer wieder dass er mit zuvor knapp
unter einer Milliarde nun knapp über
einer Milliarde Euro der kleinste
Einzelplan ist die betonen aber auch
immer wieder und wir gemeinsam hier dass
er wegen seiner Aufgaben und der
Verantwortung für die Judikative und die
dritte Gewalt im Staat eine besondere
Bedeutung hat
diese Verantwortung für den Rechtsstaat
und seine Kernaufgaben und für die
Justiz kann man allerdings nach einem
Jahr ihrer Regierung nicht wirklich
erkennen Herr Minister und warum das für
ich sehr gerne aus
sie haben nun endlich an der für sie
ersten Justizministerkonferenz
teilgenommen nach fast einem Jahr nach
Amtsantritt und das ungefähr macht auch
das Verhältnis deutlich dass zwischen
ihnen und den Ländern herrscht
es ist schon sehr bezeichnend dass alle
16 Landesministerinnen und
Landesminister beklagen dass sie und die
Justiz sich von ihm weder gehört
eingebunden ernst genommen noch
vertreten fühlen
sie alle finden dass sie nicht die Dinge
umsetzen die sie versprochen haben und
die vereinbart sind dabei gibt es im
Rechtsstaat wirklich viel zu tun
der erste Satz des Koalitionsvertrags
zum Bereich Justiz lautet ich zitiere
wir verstetigen den Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat und erweitern ihn um einen
digitalpakt für die Justiz
hiervon haben sie sich in den
Haushaltsberatungen nun explizit
verabschiedet sie werden wortbrüchig
Herr Minister auf Nachfrage haben sie
bestätigt dass diese ein Vereinbarung
für Sie obsolet ist stattdessen ist ihre
Idee ein Pakt für den digitalen
Rechtsstaat es liegt nun eine gemeinsame
Erklärung aller 16 Landesminister des
deutschen richtergrundes und der neuen
Richtervereinigung vor die sehr deutlich
macht was die Bundesländer und
Justizvertreter von der Bundesregierung
erwarten und was ihre Forderungen sind
und das geht mit ihren Vorstellungen nun
so gar nicht zusammen
neben der Fortführung des Pakts für den
Rechtsstaat der 2000 zusätzliche Stellen
für Richter und Staatsanwältinnen
umfasste beziffern die Länder alleine
den Mittelbedarf im Digitalbereich mit
350 Millionen Euro im Jahr
sie dagegen legten in der
bereinigungsfrage für den Pakt für den
digitalen Rechtsstaat eine neue
Veranschlagung von 50 Millionen im Jahr
vor und werden das sicherlich gleich als
große Errungenschaft im Haushalt
darstellen
ein Park bzw Vertrag setzt allerdings
das Einverständnis von mindestens zwei
Parteien voraus das genau gibt es aber
hier mit Nachdruck nicht
unter anderem deshalb hatten wir ja in
der Bereinigungssitzung auch nachts um
drei noch Besuch der Vorsitzenden des
Rechtsausschusses des Bundesrates die
zugleich Sprecherin der a-länder ist
ich sage nicht dass die Forderung der
Bundesländer eins zu eins umsetzt zu
setzen sind aber ihre Gesprächskultur
und Haltung führen dazu dass es hier
absehbar zu keiner Kooperation und
Zusammenarbeit führen wird
Herr Minister sie rühmen sich für ihr
Engagement für die
planungsbeschleunigung aber vielleicht
sollten sie lieber auch die
Unterstützung des Rechtsstaats durch das
Bundesjustizministerium beschleunigen
als gesetzgebungsministerium haben Sie
viele Möglichkeiten etwas für
Digitalisierung zu tun hierfür müssen
sie eigentlich auch nicht mal viel Geld
ausgeben und es wäre viel für Effizienz
und Effektivität getan ganz im Sinne von
uns Haushältern und §7 der
bundeshaushaltsordnung
ich warte auf Vorschläge aus den Ländern
sagen und schreiben Sie dabei liegen
unzählige Vorschläge vor ich nenne mal
ein paar Beispiele aus der Liste des
ijustice-rats Modernisierung des Gefahr
gemeinsam fachverfahrens-
ich kann Ihnen die Liste auch gerne
geben wenn sie bei Ihnen im Haus nicht
vorrätig ist aber wenn die Idee ist dass
der Pakt für den digitalen Rechtsstaat
ein Showact nur für Sie persönlich und
ihre neuen bundesprojekte ist dann wird
das die Justiz im Land nicht
voranbringen
[Applaus]
und ein digitalisierungsgipfel fast
anderthalb Jahre nach Start der
Bundesregierung ist eindeutig zu spät
auf ihrer Homepage sprechen sie von der
Chance die Erfolgsgeschichte des Pakt
für den Rechtsstaat damit vorzuschreiben
aber diese Chance haben sie leider
bisher verspielt dafür muss man nämlich
mit den Ländern und Akteuren reden und
arbeiten und nicht gegen sie
und erlauben Sie mir noch eine Aussage
als digitalpolitikerin sie wollen den
Status eines Landes der digitalen
Defizite endlich überwinden das ist
ehrlich gesagt bei ihrer digitalpolitik
als Ampel schon ein Treppenwitz wenn man
sich das in der Bundesregierung anschaut
sie haben völlig arthurisierte
Zuständigkeiten geschaffen eine
blutleere digitalstrategie aufgestellt
und das ganze auch noch ohne Budget
es gibt auch 2023 kein digitalbudget
kein Controlling und keine Standards
wir haben als Union einige Vorschläge
für den justizetar gemacht die leider
allesamt abgelehnt wurden
unter anderem ein klares Bekenntnis zur
Stiftung Forum recht die sie als
Koalition nicht nur nicht unterstützen
sondern der sie im Gegenteil sogar eine
mittelsperre verpasst haben ihr also
Misstrauen statt sie inhaltlich und
finanziell gut aufzustellen
wir wollten das schaffen Wesen dass eine
wichtige Säule des Rechtsstaates ist
unterstützen gerade aus der Kollision
von Ehrenamt und Berufsleben resultieren
Herausforderungen sie haben aber unseren
maßgabebeschluss nicht mitgetragen und
sich damit gegen einen weiteren
wichtigen justizzweig positioniert
was tatsächlich erfreulich ist ist dass
Sie unseren Vorschlag zumindest
teilweise übernommen haben die
besonderen Verfahren im Staatsschutz für
die Zuständigkeit auf der Bundesebene
liegt zu unterstützen aber warum
eigentlich nur in Zelle und nicht in
München wo das große nsu-verfahren
stattgefunden hat München als
Verhandlungsort wurde ausgewählt und war
nicht zwingend das Verfahren hätte auch
in einer anderen Stadt stattfinden
können
alleine die Verfahrenskosten knapp 27
Millionen Euro hätten da schon
übernommen werden müssen
so bringen sie die Länder nicht dazu mit
dem Bund untergehakt für gute
Bedingungen im Staatsschutz zu sorgen
leider bleibt mir am Schluss nur
festzustellen dass sie sich lieber auf
gesellschaftspolitische Themen
konzentrieren wie die Legalisierung von
Cannabis als sich um eine gut
aufgestellte Justiz zu kümmern
aber genau das braucht unser Land
wirklich dringend in einem guten
Miteinander alle Akteure und Ebenen und
hieran müssen sie ehrlich gesagt im
nächsten Jahr ganz hart arbeiten vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
Franziska Oppermann noch mit sehr klaren
Ansagen in Richtung Bundesjustizminister
Marco Buschmann der wird hier erst als
Achter Redner in der Debatte auftreten
aber da sind wir schon mal gespannt was
er dazu sagen wird denn der packt für
den digitalen Rechtsstaat hat ein festen
Platz in seinem Etat bekommen Torsten
lieber aus der FDP-Fraktion ist der
nächste Redner Liebe stellvertretender
Vorsitzender des Rechtsausschusses
einen Moment eine strafrechtliche
Ermittlungsmaßnahme mit Richtervorbehalt
vor die Lebensrealität in der Praxis
sieht beispielsweise in Frankfurt am
Main im Augenblick so aus der Polizist
fährt aus dem Polizeipräsidium mit der
Akte in der Hand zur Staatsanwaltschaft
einmal quer durch die Stadt lässt sich
dort in entsprechenden Antrag
unterschreiben und fährt dann direkt
postidenten wiederum quer durch die
Stadt zum Ermittlungsrichter um sich
dort die Unterschrift abzuholen dann
startet die Ermittlungsmaßnahmen ein
Beispiel zweites Beispiel die
anwaltskolleginnen und Kollegen hier in
der Runde Wissen um die Späße und
Herausforderung mit unserem wunderbaren
besonderen elektronischen
anwaltspostfach warum sage ich das dass
die Justiz Rückstände hat und Luft nach
oben in der gesamt
Digitalisierungsstrategie liegt anhand
solcher Beispiele naheliegenderweise
völlig auf der Hand und deswegen war und
ist es uns als Bundes so wichtig dass
wir genau in diesem Bereichen bei aller
Anerkenntnis der ernsthaften und
umfangreichen Bemühungen der Länder und
die Einführung der E-Akte einiges
hinterher leider etwas im Rückstand dass
der Bund beim Thema digitaler
Rechtsstaat nicht nur am Spielfeldrand
steht es ist und bleibt daher richtig
den Pakt für den Rechtsstaat und die
digitalpakt für Justiz in einem Paket zu
bündeln ein Pakt für den Rechtsstaat
ohne digitale Komponente wäre doch liebe
Freundinnen Freunde und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen überhaupt nicht
mehr zeitgemäßes braucht endlich jetzt
diesen vernetzten Ansatz
und dazu macht der Bund jetzt ein
konkretes Angebot für die kommenden vier
Jahre stehen insgesamt 200 Millionen
Euro zur Verfügung davon 50 Millionen
für das Jahr 2023 um echte
digitalisierungssprünge zu ermöglichen
die der Justiz insgesamt zugute kommen
deswegen ist es besonders wichtig dass
die Länder jetzt konstruktiv bereit sind
an dieser Stelle in die Debatte mit
einzusteigen konkrete Vorschläge zu
machen damit das eben zum gemeinsamen
Erfolgsprojekt besteht aber das sage ich
auch ganz deutlich wir werden uns als
Haushälterinnen Haushälter sehr genau
die Projekte angucken ob das was kommt
auch wirklich im bundesinteresse steht
denn das ist unsere Aufgabe die wir hier
erfüllen müssen und mein Verständnis
sage ich auch ganz offen als gerade so
angesprochen worden ist von der von der
Kollegin Oppermann so langsam fehlt mir
das Verständnis für den
Forderungskatalog der Länder an dieser
Stelle landesjustiz ist Ländersache
sowohl sachlich als auch finanziell als
auch personeller Hinsicht für mich
machen sich die Länder selbst klein wenn
immer mal immer wieder nur auf den Bund
geschaut wird und nach weiteren Geld
gefordert wird auch verfassungsrechtlich
ist die Forderung nach Personal
Mittelmeer als mehr als bedenklich und
wenn ich mir die aktuellen
Haushaltszahlen
angucke liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen wo
ich sehe dass die Länder bis Ende
September
24,4 Milliarden Euro Haushaltsüberschuss
haben während der Bund inzwischen Ende
Oktober mit mehr als 100 Milliarden Euro
im Minus steht ist das Argument zu kurz
gegriffen die Länder brauchen mehr
brauchen mehr Geld liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen deswegen setzen wir genau auf
diesen Vorschlag den wir unterbreitet
haben Sie jetzt wie gesagt an den
Ländern zuzugreifen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
rechts und Justizpolitik um auch das
klar zu sagen ist aber eben nicht nur
Innenpolitik sie hat auch eine
internationale Komponente deswegen ist
mir besonders wichtig gewesen dass wir
unterstützen konnten als
Haushaltsausschuss die weitere
mittelstärkung bei der Stiftung für
internationale rechtliche Zusammenarbeit
damit wir die Länder im Aufbruch im
östlichen Europa namentlich Moldawien
und die Ukraine und perspektivisch auch
Georgien beim Weg in den modernen
Rechtsstaat unterstützen können das ist
ein wichtiges Signal in Kriegszeiten
dass wir auch an dieser Stelle ein
Signal setzen mit dem Bundeshaushalt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das Thema planungsbeschleunigung ist
angesprochen dazu auch von mir
abschließend ein paar Worte begrüße
ausdrücklich dass es gelungen ist das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht mit einem
weiteren Senat zu stärken und dass wir
gemeinsam als Koalition die
Beschleunigung vom
planungsgenehmigungsverfahren in den
Blick zu nehmen mehr als halbieren ist
das Ziel auf das wir uns gemeinsam
verständigt haben in der Sondierung und
das wollen wir umsetzen mit dem
Koalitionsvertrag
das Bundesjustizministerium hat bereits
einen ersten ambitionierten Entwurf
vorgelegt für den Bereich der
Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung da freue ich
mich ausdrücklich auf das hoffentlich
bald beginnende parlamentarische
Verfahren dass wir hier gemeinsam
Vorankommen dabei kann es aber nicht
stehen bleiben das haben wir auch im
Koalitionsvertrag zu verabredet wir
wollen umfassend Planung und Genehmigung
beschleunigen deswegen appelliere ich an
uns alle miteinander und motiviere uns
alle dass wir das jetzt zeitnah anpacken
und fände das wäre ein wunderbarer
Einstieg in die Beschleunigung von
Planungs-
weil wir ziemlich am Ende mit dem Etat
des Justizministerium waren
durchgehalten haben vielen Dank und ich
glaube für Zustimmung zu diesen Tag
Dr Michael espendel aus der nächste
Redner für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im Saal
und bei Youtube die corona-pandemie ist
vorbei und schwupps ist man in
Deutschland vom polit-medialen
Dauerbrenner Corona nahtlos zum Thema
Ukraine übergegangen man könnte nun
meinen dass mit dem Ende der Pandemie
nur alles wieder in Ordnung sei doch das
Unrecht das während der Pandemie im
Namen der Gesundheit begangen wurde
wirkt noch fort und es bedarf dringender
Aufklärung
aber das würde bei den meisten
einfordern dass man sich auch mit dem
eigenen Fehlverhalten auseinandersetzt
auch liebe Union wenn ich überraschend
niemand von den Verantwortlichen will
das das könnte unangenehm werden und
deswegen will man lieber nicht darüber
reden aber die Betroffenen wollen
darüber reden unter dem Twitter
#wir haben mitgemacht haben Nutzer die
größten Entgleisung während der Pandemie
gesammelt das sollten sie sich dringend
mal angucken Herr Kollege Fußballtrainer
Jürgen Klopp verglich im Oktober 2021 im
Verweigerer mit Alkohol am Steuer Rod
Stewart sagt im dezember 2021 Impfgegner
sein Mörder und Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier sagte vor einem
Jahr diejenigen die sich nicht impfen
lassen setzen ihre eigene Gesundheit
aufs Spiel und sie gefährden uns alle
all diese Aussagen wurden zu einem
Zeitpunkt gemacht an dem bereits eine
erdrückende Masse an Studien und Belegen
dafür da war das ist durch die Impfung
weder eine dauerhafte Grundimmunisierung
noch einen fremdschutz gab sehr wohl
aber Nebenwirkung und trotzdem 2G auf
Weihnachtsmärkten und im Geschäften 3G
beim Arztbesuch und im Büro und jeden
Tag die fortgesetzte Entmenschlichung
von ganz normalen Bürgern die sich
einfach entschieden hatten sich nicht
impfen zu lassen aber sie alle wollen
hier den Mantel des Schweins über diese
Sache legen doch wir müssen daran
erinnern was passiert ist wir müssen
auch darüber sprechen und ich sehe hier
vor allem auch den Justizminister in der
Verantwortung warum wir haben hier im
Bundestag nämlich einen Antrag gestellt
dass die vom Bundesjustizministerium
geförderte Stiftung Forum recht
abgewickelt werden soll in den
Haushaltsberatung haben wir dann auch
die streichungsämtliche Mittel beantragt
immerhin 3,5 Millionen Euro pro Jahr was
macht denn diese Stiftung Forum recht
ihre Aufgabe sollte es nach Gesetz sein
aktuelle Fragen von Recht und
Rechtsstaat als Grundvoraussetzung einer
funktionsfähigen und lebendigen
Demokratie öffentlich mit Beteiligung
der Bürger zu thematisieren und jetzt
raten Sie mal was diese Stiftung vor
kurzem so gemacht hat nichts diese
Stiftung ist schlicht und einfach nach
untätig geblieben seit sie 2019 von den
Altparteien gegründet wurde hier können
wir einige Millionen Euro an
Steuergeldern sparen seit wir den Antrag
auf Abwicklung gestellt haben ist
allerdings etwas mehr Bewegung den Laden
gekommen es gibt jetzt einen
Presseverteiler und als zuständiger
Berichterstatter Einzelplan 7 bin ich da
seit Ende Oktober auch plötzlich drin
und wissen sie zum welchem Thema diese
Stiftung mich als erstes eingeladen hat
frau Kollegin ausgerechnet zum Thema
verschwörungserzählungen als wären die
letzten drei Jahren nicht eine Mischung
aus Orwells 1984 und Farben der Tiere
gewesen
lieber Herr Bundesminister ganz zufällig
waren sie kurz nach unserem Antrag zur
Abwicklung dieser untätigen Stiftung
Ende Oktober auch zum Antrittsbesuch
dort ich werde das mal als direktes
Bekenntnis zu den 3,5 Millionen Euro mit
denen ihr Haus diesen Hort der
Untätigkeit auch weiterhin mit deutschen
Steuergeld fördern will aber wenn sie
das schon machen dann sorgen sie doch
wenigstens dafür dass man dort auch
tatsächlich eine Beitrag zu Demokratie
und Rechtsstaat leistet die Aufarbeitung
der Pandemie und der staatliche Angriff
auf unsere Freiheit und Bürgerrechte
wäre ein solcher Beitrag wir können ihn
und dieser Stiftung sehr gerne bei der
Organisation helfen weil Betroffene sind
uns in großer Menge bekannt vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]
gucken Sie sich mal an was die machen
folgende bitte mal die Veröffentlichung
von denen das ist nichts mit Rechtsstaat
der Rechtsstaat ist wichtig die machen
ihre Aufgabe einfach nicht das sagt
sogar die Kollegin von der SPD teilweise
wir haben das sogar im
Haushaltsausschuss kritisiert aber
sie hatten ja noch Redezeit aber ihre
Rede schon abgeschlossen
alles gut
ist natürlich hier ist die nächste
Rednerin in dieser Aussprache zum Etat
des bundesjustizministers ist natürlich
er kommt aus der SPD-Fraktion ist
Mitglied im Haushalts und im
Rechtsausschuss und sie war vor ihrer
Zeit als Abgeordnete Rechtsanwältin und
Notarin
sehr geehrter Herr Bundesminister
Buschmann sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren auf den Tribünen sehr geehrter
Vertreter auf der bundesratsbank
im justizhaushalt also im Einzelplan 07
es ist schon mehrfach gesagt worden
haben da gesagt Ausgaben von 953
Millionen Euro eingestellt Einnahmen
rund 640 Millionen Euro und Frau Obama
ich gebe Ihnen Recht es kann eigentlich
immer nur wieder darauf hingewiesen
werden wie klein der Haushalt ist und
auch wie
kann sich die
Ausgaben für Personal darstellen nämlich
mit 65%, also viele Mittel die gebunden
sind aber auch eine hohe Deckungsquote
67% und ich finde man muss es oft genug
sagen damit es irgendwann auch mal
ankommt deswegen deswegen ist es logisch
dass es da auch nur sehr wenig Spielraum
für Projekte Förderprogramme oder
zusätzliche neue Aufgaben gibt wie in
anderen Haushaltsplänen wo ich doch
wesentlich mehr Geld zur Verfügung habe
was uns in der großen Koalition leider
nicht gelungen ist haben wir jetzt aber
umsetzen können es ist auch nur ein
kleiner Betrag aber trotzdem eine
Anerkennung 75.000 Euro für die
Initiative European loyers in lesos die
von deutschen Anwaltsverein unterstützt
werden die Kollegen und Kollegen werden
dazu noch mehr ausführen herzliche Grüße
an Frau Dr Kindermann steht da drauf den
Stein es hat sich jetzt endlich gelohnt
das Geld bereitgestellt
500.000 Euro auch ein kleiner Betrag
gehen an die Deutsche Stiftung für
internationale rechtliche Zusammenarbeit
damit sollen EU-Beitrittskandidaten auf
ihrem Weg in die EU unterstützt werden
auch das ein sinnvolles Projekt wo meine
Kollegin noch und Kollegen ausführen
werden
aufgrund der Haushaltslage konnten
natürlich nicht alle Projekte im Umfang
unterstützt werden wie es wünschenswert
gewesen wäre und Herr Dr Hessen Diller
ich möchte da auch gerade zu dem
stiftung-forum Recht noch weiter
ausführen allerdings etwas anders als
Sie es vielleicht angekündigt haben
diese Stiftung des Parlaments soll
langfristig weiter aufwachsen das ist
uns allen vielleicht nur nicht ihnen Sie
Ihr Antrag die Stiftung aufzulösen ein
wichtiges Anliegen
aber
so ehrlich muss man auch sein ja selbst
wenn man Geld bereitstellt um zu den
dreieinhalb Millionen stehende auf jeden
Fall gibt es durchaus auch mal die ein
oder andere Kritik bis sowas ins Laufen
kommt und ich denke das werden wir sehr
konstruktiv ich gucke jetzt mal Renate
Künast an auch sehr konstruktiv
begleiten ja aber wir werden es trotzdem
konstruktiv begleiten
aber dass wir dass die Stiftung
aufwachsen soll da sind wir uns schon
einig
die dass die reaktorium hat am 5 Oktober
das Kuratorium und ich glaube er seit
sie waren auch da über den
stiftungshaushalt in Höhe von 5,2
Millionen beschließen lassen obwohl im
Regierungsentwurf für die Stiftung ein
Betrag von 3,5 Millionen eingestellt war
das kann man noch als Hoffnung auf
positive Veränderung in der
Bereinigungssitzung einordnen das
Kuratorium wurde aber zu diesem
Zeitpunkt nicht einmal davon den
Kenntnis gesetzt dass der
Bundesrechnungshof eine umfangreiche
prüfungsmitteilung an die Stiftung
übersand hatte und diese Mitteilung auch
auf Nachfrage der Kuratoriumsmitglieder
nicht zur Verfügung gestellt wurde unter
anderem aus diesem Grund haben wir im
stiftungshaushalt einen Betrag von
zunächst 200.000 € gesperrt bis
zumindest nach der Stellungnahme des
Direktoriums an den Rechnungshof und
deren Bericht dann vorliegt ich will
weiter darauf hinweisen wir haben diese
Stiftung als Parlament auf den Weg
gebracht aufgrund der Initiative und
eines enorm ehrenamtlichen Engagements
der Zivilgesellschaft in Karlsruhe und
ich stehe dazu wir wollen die auch
weiterhin aktiv begleiten uns könnten
wir den Antrag der AFD statt geben nein
das wollen wir ja gar nicht ich gehe
aber davon aus dass wir hier alle an
einem Strang ziehen um dieses
Leuchtturmprojekt auch als sicheren und
vertrauensvollen Wegweiser in unserem
Rechtsstaat zu etablieren ich gehe aber
auch davon aus dass eine Stiftung die
vom Parlament gegründet wird dann auch
das Parlament an allen Stellen
entsprechend einbindet und wenn sie mal
ihre Kolleginnen
Elisabeth winkelmeier Bäcker Fragen die
war auch nicht so ganz begeistert als
wir diese Leitbild Diskussion im
Kuratorium einfach nur abstimmen sollten
und gar nicht eingebunden waren deswegen
müssen wir uns da zusammenraufen um das
wirklich gut auf den Weg zu bringen
wir haben diese Woche bereits mehrfach
darüber gesprochen ob und in welchem
Umfang und auf welcher Grundlage wir als
Bund verpflichtet sein könnten die
Länder weil der auferfüllung ihrer
ureigenen Aufgaben zu unterstützen
inhaltlich geht es bei diesem
Mischfinanzierung starten im Einzelplan
07 um den Pakt für den Rechtsstaat der
in der letzten Legislatur geschmiedet
wurde
ein gut funktionierender Rechtsstaat ist
wichtig für einen guten
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhang und
dafür ist ausreichend Personal eine
wichtige Grundvoraussetzung ich glaube
darüber gibt es auch überhaupt keinen
Streit mit dem Pakt sollten damals 2000
Stellen in der Justiz neu geschaffen
werden wohlgemerkt Personal in der
länderjustiz packt für den Rechtsstaat
das hört sich erst einmal sehr modern
und zukunftsorientiert an gemäß Artikel
30 unseres Grundgesetzes ist die
Ausübung der staatlichen Befugnisse und
die Erfüllung der staatlichen Aufgaben
Sache der Länder so weit das Grundgesetz
keine andere Regelung trifft oder
zulässt für den Bereich Personal in der
Länder Justiz findet sich aber keine
andere Regelungen im Grundgesetz
in der letzten Legislatur wurde dann
aber nicht über den bundesjustizhaushalt
sondern über die Umsatzsteuerverteilung
den Ländern das Geld für dieses Personal
zur Verfügung gestellt im Bundeshaushalt
des Justizministeriums ist eben
verfassungsrechtlich kein Raum um diesen
personalaufwuchs in den Ländern zu
finanzieren
und zur Umsetzung des
Koalitionsvertrages finden wir nach der
bereinigungsgesetzung nun ein Betrag von
50 Millionen der Kollege lieb hat dazu
schon aufgeführt für 2023 sowie
Verpflichtungsermächtigung für die
laufenden Jahre zur Digitalisierung der
Justiz und zwar im Rahmen des Pakt für
den digitalen Rechtsstaat und jetzt kann
man darüber streiten was ist jetzt eine
Erweiterung des Pakt für den
Rechtsstaats erfordert das dass zwei
packte nebeneinander bestehen bleiben
oder kann man das auch gut
zusammenführen und ich finde die
Ausführung dazu vom Kollegen lieb sehr
überzeugend dass eben ein Rechtsstaat
ohne Digitalisierung in der heutigen
Gesellschaft und dem heutigen
Rechtsstaat nicht mehr wegzudenken ist
also das ist Grundvoraussetzung ist und
dieses Angebot der Unterstützung bei der
Digitalisierung finde ich auch sehr gut
im Rahmen von Projekten können
ländervorhaben gefördert werden wenn die
entwickelten Anwendung später von der
gesamtjustiz genutzt werden können und
da hatte vorhin jemand dazwischen Stufen
naja dann werden nur oder ich glaube
aber wenn sie hat es gesagt da werden
nur Projekte das Ministers auf
Bundesebene gefördert nein das ist es
nicht so wer das Eckpunktepapier liest
dazu das besteht aus vier Säulen und die
zweite Säule sind Vorhaben von Bund und
Ländern gemeinsam und da wird davon
ausgegangen dass darin 80 Prozent der
Mittel abfließen sollen da sind wir mal
gespannt wie das umgesetzt wird und da
haben wir als parlamentarium
berichterstatte ja auch den Finger drauf
ich möchte dann noch mal zu der
berüchtigten Bereinigungssitzung kommen
wo uns Frau gallina morgens um 2:30 Uhr
erzählt hat welche Forderungen die
Justizminister aufgestellt haben in der
in der Justizministerkonferenz und wie
wichtig es sei dass eben weiterhin 200
Millionen Euro zur Verfügung gestellt
werden wenn ich mir diese
Gesprächskultur angucke die da in der
Bereinigungssitzung beherrscht hat dann
kann ich mir ansatzweise vorstellen
obwohl ich nicht dabei war wie eine
Justizministerkonferenz möglicherweise
abläuft wenn 16 Justizminister der
Länder dort nutzen und Forderungen
stellen und der Justizminister sagt ja
es ist eigentlich so nicht möglich lasst
uns doch das zusammen auf den Weg
bringen es sind gute Projekte die
vorgelegt werden sollen wir werden die
Hand drauf haben als Parlament deswegen
haben wir an die Sitzung unterbrochen
und haben die 50 Millionen gesperrt und
werden also ein wachsam ein Auge drauf
haben dass eben gerade auch Geld bei den
Ländern ankommt
vielen Dank für Ihre aufmerksam
keit so und da hat uns ist der Dildo aus
der SPD-Fraktion noch ein wenig
teilhaben lassen an dem Abläufen einer
der wichtigsten Sitzungen die es im
Bundestag geht nämlich das
Haushaltsausschuss das ist und des
sogenannter bereinigungssitzer Sitzung
wo noch mal am Ende der
Haushaltsberatung alles detailliert
durchgeguckt wird Susanna hin ich wäre
so ist sambold frühere Parteivorsitzende
der Linken jetzt ob Frau im
Rechtsausschuss
vor ein paar Wochen davon gesprochen das
Recht auf die Höhe der
gesellschaftlichen Wirklichkeit bringen
zu wollen
sie haben ein gutes Ziel und ich will
auch hier gar nicht behaupten dass das
was ihr Haus im letzten Jahr vorgelegt
hat
umgesetzt hat angestoßen hat falsch oder
unsinnig wäre im Detail haben wir
allerdings erhebliche Differenzen was
wahrscheinlich hier im Raum niemanden
überrascht
und
viele Differenzen gibt es weil wir
offenbar völlig unterschiedliche
Auffassung davon haben was genau die
Höhe der gesellschaftlichen Wirklichkeit
ist
denn es kommt natürlich auf den
Standpunkt an von dem aus man auf die
Wirklichkeit blickt was bedeutet von
oben sieht die Welt wesentlich anders
aus als von unten
ich will ein Beispiel benennen wir als
LINKE haben uns in der vergangenen
Legislaturperiode damit es noch
gemeinsam mit den Grünen
dafür stark gemacht eine Rechtsberatung
für geflüchtete an den Außengrenzen der
Europäischen Union durch den Bund zu
unterstützen
solche Rechtshilfe löst natürlich nicht
das Grundproblem der grenzabschottung
das will ich ja auch ganz klar sagen
aber sie kann natürlich ankommenden
Menschen helfen zu ihrem Recht zu kommen
ihre Koalition hat diese Idee nun
aufgegriffen eine finanzielle Förderung
der Initiative European neues in Lesbos
beschlossen
die Initiative die unter anderem vom
deutschen Anwaltsverein geführt wird
bietet unabhängige Rechtsberatung an den
EU-Grenzen an
auch das ist gut dennoch meinen weit von
der Höhe der gesellschaftlichen
Wirklichkeit entfernt wenn man dafür im
Haushalt nur 75.000 Euro zur Verfügung
steht
mit diesem Betrag kann man hier
zueinander nicht mal eine Anwältin für
ein Jahr finanzieren
es tut auch angesichts der schrecklichen
Bilder von Menschen unwürdigen Umgang an
den EU-Außengrenzen zumindest mir
wirklich weh wenn sie sich selbst in
auch noch für Kostengünstigkeit und
Kosten Nutzen Verhältnis in Metall loben
apropos Anwälte
immer wieder werden in der
Bundesrepublik Menschen in abschließend
abschieberhaft gesteckt somit ihrer
Freiheit beraubt ohne dass Sie sich
dagegen wehren können wenn man aber mal
mit Leuten redet sie sich damit
auskennen zum Beispiel in dem
Rechtsanwalt Peter freibusch der über
2000 Menschen in Abschiebehaft begleitet
hat und vertreten hat dann weiß man dass
bei etwa der Hälfte
gerichtlich festgestellt wurde dass sie
zu Unrecht im Gefängnis saßen
wäre es also nicht
auf der Höhe der gesellschaftlichen
Wirklichkeit analog zur
Pflichtverteidigung um Strafprozess auch
eine Pflicht Beiordnung von Anwältinnen
in Verfahren zur Anordnung von
Abschiebehaft gesetzlich einzuführen
sie haben in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
ausdrücklich die rechte und die
Verteidigung von Beschuldigten
hochgehalten
aber dann muss es auch etwas da muss
auch etwas kommen was der höher der
gesellschaftlichen Wirklichkeit
tatsächlich entspricht
wir denken ja zum Beispiel an die
Ausweitung der Pflichtverteidigung oder
die Entkriminalisierung von bagatelliken
um eine ziemlich einfache Sache geht
und zwar Gerechtigkeit und Rechtsstaat
dürfen nicht vom Einkommen abhängig sein
oder vom Einkommen Weg entscheiden also
von der sozialen Lage abhängig machen
wie entschieden wird
ich zitiere mit Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin
das Recht hierzulande begünstigt jene
die begütert sind es benachteiligt die
die wenig oder nicht haben das ist
nichts was ich mir selbst ausgedacht
habe es steht in einem Buch eines
Journalisten die mich weiterhin viele
Leserinnen und Leser Wünsche und ich
empfehle ist auch ihnen es gibt
armutsbestrafung in diesem Land
und da sie diese Klassenjustiz die
täglich stattfindet offenbar auch nicht
mehr dulden wollen sind Sie auf dem Weg
die ersatzfreiheit Straßen zu
reformieren
andererseits müsste ich mich fragen ob
sie einen Vorschlag den Sie gemacht
haben nur gemacht haben um Geld
einzusparen
was man dem Reförmchen auch unterstellen
könnte
und deswegen gehen sie leider den Weg
nicht zu Ende und an die Adresse von
Frau Innenministerin Faser
die Reformen die Sie Herr Buschmann auf
dem Weg bringen die erfreuen uns
natürlich ein Stück weit eine
Erleichterung bedeutet es ist aber nicht
das was wir tatsächlich politisch
brauchen und das Frau Innenministerin
Phaser das noch mit fragwürdigen
Behauptung tobidiert ist nun auch nicht
wirklich
die Höhe der gesellschaftlichen
Wirklichkeit
und lassen sie mich zum Abschluss noch
etwas zum Pakt für den Rechtsstaat sagen
die FDP hat ja gern Kollegen
es tut mir leid aber Sie müssen einen
Punkt setzen gut Gerechtigkeit braucht
personelle und sächliche Ausstattung der
Justiz in den Ländern und nicht alles
ist zwei Punkt Null vielen Dank
Susanne ich will so in der Debatte über
den Etat zum
Justizministerium und da hat sie
abgehoben auf den Aspekt Gerechtigkeit
eben Rechtsstaaten nächster Redner in
dieser Aussprache wir Bruno Hönel sein
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
er ist Mitglied im Haushaltsausschuss
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine Milliarde
Euro das ist die magische Marke die der
Tat des Justizministeriums in diesem
Haushalt jetzt überschritten hat das ist
natürlich nicht per se ein Grund zur
Freude aber es zeigt eben schon dass wir
Prozesse in den Justizbehörden
modernisieren und dass wir unseren
liberalen Rechtsstaat stärken aber ich
glaube gerade in diesen Zeiten wo wir in
vielen Ländern in brutalerweise
verdeutlicht bekommen so was das Fehlen
einer unabhängigen Gerichtsbarkeit führt
wo Menschen der Willkür der
justizschutzlos ausgesetzt sind da
dürfen wir nicht müde werden den Wert
unserer freiheitlich demokratischen
Grundordnung unseres Liberalen
Rechtsstaats zu betonen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
[Applaus]
Verhältnismäßigkeit verpflichtet und
ihre jüngsten Vorstöße liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Union
klimaaktivisten in vorbeuhaft zu bringen
sind alles aber sicherlich nicht
verhältnismäßig wir haben für den Umgang
mit diesen Protesten geltende Gesetze
und die sind ausreichend liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und dass sie
von der Union sich hier einzig und
allein an der Protestform abarbeiten
ohne sich mit dem berechtigten Grund der
Aktion auseinanderzusetzen das zeigt
doch das Pudels Kern nämlich dass in der
Klimaschutz völlig egal ist und dass sie
ihre Verantwortung von 16 Jahren total
Versagen in der Klimapolitik bis heute
nicht aufgearbeitet haben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe gesagt
wir modernisieren unsere Justiz wir
gehen jetzt endlich erste Schritte um
unsere Justizbehörden auf die Höhe der
Zeit zu bringen mit den
digitalisierungsmitteln investieren wir
in den nächsten Jahren Bundes-
Millionen Euro für die Digitalisierung
der Justiz sicherlich reichen diese
Mittel nicht aus um all die Altlasten
die wir geerbt haben zu beseitigen aber
klar ist eben auch dass wir uns da jetzt
endlich mal auf den Weg machen das ist
ein Erfolg dieser Regierung wir bringen
das jetzt voran und das ist zuallererst
einmal eine gute Nachricht für die
Justiz
aber auch neben diesen Großprojekt
setzen wir mit diesem Haushalt
vielfältige Akzente ein Beispiel dafür
ist die Unterstützung für hate aid die
wir im Laufe des Verfahrens mit 500.000
€ an Barmitteln und
Verpflichtungsermächtigung Umfang von
1,2 Millionen ausstatten digitale Gewalt
hast und Hetze im Netz sind ein
komplexes und immer größer werdendes
Problem bei der Bekämpfung stehen wir
noch am Anfang das muss man schon
ehrlich sagen und ob Twitter unter Elon
Muster an Fortschritt ist das will ich
ganz stark bezweifeln und doch hate aid
leistet hier wertvolle Arbeit klärt auf
unterstützt Betroffene und ist dabei
erfolgreich erst kürzlich konnte die
klimaaktivistin Luisa Neubauer über hate
aid eine Klage gegen einen rechten Autor
gewinnen als Koalition stellen wir uns
diesen Rechtsbrüchen konsequent entgegen
und die strukturelle Verstärkung von
hält er ist da wirklich ein großer
Erfolg im Sinne der Betroffenen die wir
nicht alleine lassen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
worüber ich mich auch sehr freue ist
dass wir einen neuen Klimaschutz Senat
beim Bundesverwaltungsgericht schaffen
da waren wir zwölf Stellen im Haushalt
eingestellt die dazu beitragen werden
das Planungen von Stromleitungen von
Nord nach Süd aber eben auch
beispielsweise von Windkraftanlagen
beschleunigt werden mit diesem Senat
machen wir klar alle reden von
planungsbeschleunigen wir setzen Sie
konkret um und beschleunigen so auch die
Energiewende mit diesem Haushalt
zudem haben wir die Deutsche Stiftung
für internationale rechtliche
Zusammenarbeit mit 500.000 Euro
zusätzlich gestärkt die Stiftung
arbeitet unter anderem an der
eu-beitrittsperspektive der Ukraine und
von Moldau mit den zusätzlichen Mitteln
können diese Verfahren gerade vor dem
Hintergrund des Krieges verstärkt in den
Blick genommen und forciert werden das
ist nur ein Beispiel in diesem Jahr das
zeigt wir nehmen unsere europäische
Verantwortung war auch in diesem
justizhaushalt lassen Sie mich noch
zusammenfassend sagen wir sind mit
diesem guten Weg und sie Justiz
digitaler und Bürger nahezu gestalten
wir Grüne bleiben da aber auch weiter
dran vor dem Hintergrund der hohen
Stellenbedarf in Justizbehörden haben
wir da sicherlich noch einige Diskussion
vor uns gerade auch im Hinblick auf den
Pakt für den Rechtsstaat der nicht
gleichzusetzen ist mit den
digitalisierungsmitteln es geht darum in
den kommenden Jahren das aufzuholen was
von Parteien die sich im Wahlkampf mit
Sicherheit für Deutschland Brüsten
verschlafen wurde die Verwaltung und
Justiz auf die Höhe der Zeit zu bringen
daran arbeiten wir mit diesem Haushalt
herzlichen Dank
Bruno höhnel aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen hat zu Beginn seiner Rede
noch mal die Größe des etas angesprochen
dass die Justizministeriums eine Komma
01 Milliarden Euro umfasst ja damit ist
der Etat des Justizministeriums der
kleinste aller Ministerien also stehen
in erster Linie Personalkosten zu Buche
für das Ministerium aber auch für
angegliederte Behörden wie Gerichte zum
Beispiel den Bundesgerichtshof das
bundesverfallverwaltungsgerichts und der
Bundesfinanzhof Günter Krings der rechts
politische Sprecher der
unionsfraktionspolitik
geprägt ist dieses erste ampeljahr in
der Rechtspolitik von
Absichtserklärungen eckpunktepapieren
aber eben kaum von konkreten
Gesetzentwürfen die das Kabinett
passiert hätten aus einem Wasserfall von
Ankündigungen tropft bis heute ein
kleines Rinnsal der Gesetzgebung
das solche Untätigkeit am Beginn einer
Wahlperiode übrigens
keins folgt
aperiode da hatten wir nämlich vor der
Sommerpause schon große
Gesetzgebungsvorhaben abgeschlossen etwa
das
musterfeststellungstage gesetzt ohne die
Anträge unserer Unionsfraktion würde der
Rechtsausschuss derzeit fast nur noch
Themen andere Ausschüsse mit beraten
und der direkte Vergleich zwischen
unseren Initiativen und dem eigenen
Vakuum ist der Ampel im Rechtsausschuss
offenbar noch wirklich peinlich dort
Wochen Anhörungen zu unseren Anträgen
verhindert Beispiele sind der
Gesetzentwurf zu Unterbringung in einer
Erziehungsanstalt unser Antrag zu
ip-adressenspeicherung oder die
digitalen Mitgliederversammlungen im
Vereinsrecht
unseren Antrag mit dem wir die längst
überfällig Unterstützung der
Bundesregierung für einen für eine
internationale Sondertribunal gegen den
russischen Angriffskrieg einfordern der
wurde gleich ganz in den Auswärtigen
Ausschuss weggeschoben
die Rechtspolitik meine Damen und Herren
lieber einst einmal das Herzstück der
Gesetzgebung im Bundestag unter der
Ampel droht nun der Herzstillstand
dass sie hier
oppositionsrechte unterminieren ist die
eine Sache das andere ist aber was sie
damit unserer parlamentarischen
Demokratie antun wenn wir gemeinsam in
Europa für die Macht des Rechts werben
wollen dann wirkt das wenig glaubhaft
wenn für Sie im Deutschen Bundestag nur
die Macht der Mehrheit zählt
und ich muss das leider ergänzen mit
ihrer Mehrheit schauen Sie auch nicht
davor zurück die Entscheidungen von
Richterinnen und Richtern in unserem
Land zu diskreditieren
sie stellen die neue ich finde absurde
gesetzgebungsregel auf dass bei
Änderungen einer Norm nicht nur das
Recht für die Zukunft angepasst wird
sondern zugleich die Gerichtsurteile der
Vergangenheit kassiert werden so etwa
bei der beschlossenen Zulassung von
Werbung für Abtreibungen oder bei der
geplanten Cannabis Legalisierung bezogen
auf das Bundeszentralregister
ich will Ihnen ja gerne glauben dass das
nicht ihre Absicht ist aber auch so kann
man das Vertrauen in die Gerichte als
zentrale Institutionen unsere Staates
untergraben
ich habe das gesagt mangels Masse kann
man ihre Rechtspolitik ja bisher kaum
anhand von Gesetzgebung beurteilen
schauen wir aber einmal auf die diversen
Ankündigungen zu Gesetzen so kann ich
dem aktuellen Stillstand der
Gesetzgebung sogar wieder manchmal etwas
abgewinnen dazu nur zwei Kostproben beim
sogenannten selbstbestimmungsgesetz soll
die Trennung von biologischem und
rechtlichen Geschlecht nicht mehr eine
Ausnahme sein als solche brauchen wir
natürlich die Möglichkeit ist zu trennen
sondern Geschlecht und Vorname sollen
jährlich frei wählbar werden passend
dazu ermuntert die Familienministerin
Kinder schon heute pubertätsblocker
einzunehmen und auch mit der geplanten
abstammungsrechtsreform ist ein
Familien- und gesellschaftspolitischer
Umbau geplant mit solchen und ähnlichen
Projekten wollen sie das
Koordinatensystem unserer Gesellschaft
massiv nach links verschieben
wenn dann ein angefressener
fdp-vorsitzender am Abend der
niedersachsenwahl beklagt die FDP werde
in der Öffentlichkeit als linke Partei
in einer linken Koalition wahrgenommen
so hat das Herr Lindner gesagt
so sollt ihr doch mal sein
Justizminister fragen ob das vielleicht
einfach auch an linker Politik liegen
kann
und das ist ganz einfach
dass es eben genauso wie in der
Wirtschaft wer mit dem Image seines
Produktes nicht zufrieden ist der kann
viel Geld fürs Marketing ausgeben besser
ist es das Produkt einmal zu
überarbeiten
und dieser problematische Kurs verschont
auch das Wirtschaftsrecht nicht ich
denke das Hinweisgeber Schutzgesetz das
ist in Kern Europa rechtlich vorgegeben
aber eben nicht in der Ausprägung in der
öffentlichen Anhörung haben das
Sachverständige zerpflückt insbesondere
wegen der übermäßigen Belastungen der
Wirtschaft und dieser Bürokratie
aufwuchs ist eben das glatte Gegenteil
des vom Finanzminister versprochenen
belastungsmoratoriums ich empfehle bei
diesem Gesetz daher gehe zurück auf Los
das richtige soll gemacht werden und das
möglichst schnell
und schauen wir einmal in den Haushalt
dann steht dieser ja linken Gesetzgebung
auch noch eine kleinmütige
Haushaltspolitik gegenüber für
Kolleginnen Hoffmann hatte einige schon
zur ausgeführt aus ihrem Haushalt
spricht an all- und Ecken an allen Ecken
und Enden ein minimalistisches
Verständnis von der Rolle des Bundes in
der Rechtspolitik den Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat soll es nur noch digital und
projektbezogen geben da war mal mehr
vorgeschlagen worden die Fortführung
unseres von der CDU initiierten
rechtsstaatspraxis das haben sie jetzt
einfach mal klammheimlich abgeräumt auch
dass sie die Bundesfinanzierung des
Regensburger ostrechtsinstituts
schrittweise auf Null zurückfahren
wollen das mag ein kleines Beispiel sein
aber ein besonders skandalöses sie
verweisen hier im Ausschuss lapidar auf
den Freistaat Bayern der sich doch um
die rechts Entwicklung in Osteuropa
kümmern solle wir meinen gerade in
diesen Zeiten hätten die Rechtsordnung
unserer europäischen Partner die
Aufmerksamkeit auch des Bundes verdient
meine Damen und Herren besonders bitter
ist schließlich dass ihr mangelndes
Engagement für den Rechtsstaat im
föderalen Verbund sein Entsprechung auch
im fehlenden effektiven Einsatz für die
schwächsten unserer Gesellschaft findet
nämlich im mangelnden Einsatz für unsere
Kinder sie weigern sich in das Thema
kennen Sie den Spielraum des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs zur
Speicherung der IP-Adressen zu nutzen
damit verhindern Sie die Aufklärung von
schweren Missbrauchsfällen wir lassen
Ihnen das nicht durchgehen wenn das
immer wieder ansprechen die Möglichkeit
während der europäischen Recht da etwas
zu tun sie machen nur etwas wie Fries
was so gut wie gar nichts bringt wir
fordern weiter ein effektive
Schutzinstrument für unsere
kindereinheiten
meine Damen und Herren ich verstehe dass
das alles schmerzhaft für Sie ist
ich könnte diese Mängellisten auch noch
fortsetzen ich will das mit Blick auf
die Zeit nicht tun aber ein Unterschied
ist ziemlich deutlich geworden nämlich
der zwischen Ihrer und unserer
Rechtspolitik sie sehen die
Rechtspolitik als Vehikel für den Umbau
der Gesellschaft wir sehen sie als
gemeinsames und gesamtstaatliche Aufgabe
zur Stärkung des rechtsstaats-
vielen herzlichen Dank
Günther Krings der rechtspolitische
Sprecher der Unionsfraktion am Ende noch
mal mit dem Ziel des Justizministeriums
dessen Aufgabe so heißt es jetzt mal von
neutralen Boden ist die Sicherung und
Fortentwicklung des Rechtsstaates im
Übrigen hat Günter Krings dem
Ministerium und dem Minister Untätigkeit
vorgeworfen man vermisse Gesetzentwürfe
im Rechtsausschuss jetzt dazu der
Minister direkt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe Zuschauerinnen und liebe
Zuschauer
heute auf den Tag genau von 9 Monaten
hat Russland die Ukraine überfallen
und dieser Überfall war nicht nur ein
Verbrechen an sich dieser Krieg wird in
verbrecherischer Weise geführt deshalb
ist es nicht nur ein Angriff auf
Freiheit auf Selbstbestimmung und auf
Demokratie es ist ein Angriff auf das
Völkerrecht und deshalb haben alle
zivilisierten Staaten hat Deutschland
hat die Bundesregierung und ich hoffe
wir haben mir einen Konsens im Haus die
verdammte Pflicht sicherzustellen dass
das Völkerrecht und das Völkerstrafrecht
nicht nur auf dem Papier geschrieben
steht wir stehen ein für den Satz dass
der Gedanke wenn die Waffen sprechen
schweigt das Recht der Vergangenheit
angehört wir alle gemeinsam haben die
Pflicht sicherzustellen dass wir eine
Welt arbeiten in der der Satz gilt wenn
die Waffen sprechen lässt sich das Recht
nicht den Mund verbieten meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
es ist diese gemeinsame Überzeugung die
mich nach Washington geführt hat dem ich
nach New York geführt hatte mich vor
kurzem erst nach Kiew geführt hat um
dort mit meinem amerikanischen Kollegen
darüber zu sprechen wie wir noch
effektiver zusammenarbeiten um diesem
Gedanken zu Wirklichkeit zu verhelfen
ich habe in New York mit den Feinden
Nationen gesprochen ich habe mit beiden
ukrainischen Botschaftern in den USA bei
den Vereinten Nationen und bei der
deutschen Bundesregierung gesprochen und
ich habe mir in Kiew die Lage erläutern
lassen und deshalb haben wir auch zu
einem weiteren Schritt gegriffen der
schon jetzt historisch ist das erste Mal
in der Geschichte werden die
Justizminister der G7 Staaten hier in
Berlin zusammenkommen um dafür zu sorgen
dass wir effektiv und auch unter
Berücksichtigung der besonderen
Situation von
Opferzeugen schlimmster Kriegsverbrechen
effektiv ermitteln und wir haben die
Pflicht dafür zu sorgen vor dem
Hintergrund unserer Geschichte und nicht
nur weil wir die sieben Präsidentschaft
haben es ist das Erbe in Nürnberg es ist
das Erbe unserer Geschichte das uns dazu
bringen muss eines sicherzustellen
nirgendwo auf der Welt dürfen sich
Kriegsverbrecher sicher fühlen erst
recht nicht hier in Deutschland meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
der
verbrecherische Angriffskrieg Russlands
auf die Ukraine ist das Schlimmste
Symptom einer Entwicklung die schon seit
längerem im Gange ist nämlich einer
offenen Konfrontation zwischen dem
Gedanken der liberalen Demokratie auf
der einen Seite und einem neuen
Autoritarismus
und das ist natürlich nicht über Nacht
gekommen und deshalb ist es glaube ich
richtig an einem solchen Punkt wie jetzt
auch sich die Frage zu stellen wie kam
das eigentlich denn es ist ja einmal
völlig anders gewesen
in den 90er Jahren des letzten
Jahrhunderts hatte die liberale
Demokratie eine Strahlkraft auf der
ganzen Welt hatte das was man softpower
genannt hat dass man glaubte irgendwann
braucht man vielleicht gar keine
hardpower mehr Menschen fast auf der
ganzen Welt haben sich gewünscht so zu
leben wie wir es tun und das hatte
sicherlich mit zwei Dingen zu tun und
ich will das heute in Erinnerung rufen
weil darüber etwas oberflächliche zum
Teil gesprochen wird
das eine Element war dass in der Art und
Weise wie wir leben wir jedem einzelnen
Menschen würde und Recht zu teil werden
lassen und diese Strahlkraft hat
natürlich ein Einfluss eingebüßt nach
der Jahrtausendwende als wir überall
auch in den liberalen Demokratien im
Rahmen des Vor- und Terror tief und viel
zu tief wie wir heute wissen in die
bürgerlichen Freiheitsrechte
eingegriffen haben und Menschen auf der
ganzen Welt sich gefragt haben ist das
nicht ein innerer Widerspruch und
deshalb
und deshalb möchte ich heute sagen wer
angesichts des russischen angriffskriegs
der Meinung ist dass eine liberale das
heißt eine an Verhältnismäßigkeit und
den Grundrechten orientierte kriminal-
und Sicherheitspolitik aus der Zeit
gefallen wäre den sage ich jetzt erst
recht weil wir müssen zeigen dass wir
auch in Zeiten der Krise zu unseren
eigenen Werten stehen das macht uns nach
außen glaubwürdig meine Damen und Herren
und ich will noch einen sagen Herr
Kollege Prinz ich will noch eins sagen
Herr Kollege Krings wenn wir China
anderslose massenhafte Speicherung von
personenbezogenen Daten vorwerfen dann
dürfen wir sie selbst nicht betreiben
das ist rechtlich nach innen und das
schafft Glaubwürdigkeit nach außen Herr
Kollegen
der zweite Grund dafür dass diese
Strahlkraft die die liberalen
Demokratien einmal ausgestrahlt haben
vielleicht nachgelassen hat ist aber
auch etwas anderes
es ist die Beobachtung gewesen dass die
Menschen in der Welt gesehen haben dass
die Art und Weise wie wir unser
Gemeinwesen organisieren auch wahnsinnig
erfolgreich war sehr lange wir haben
Wohlstand geschaffen wir haben eine
öffentliche Infrastruktur geschaffen wir
konnten sozialen Ausgleich schaffen und
wir haben die Erkenntnisse der
Wissenschaft sehr schnell nutzbar
gemacht für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
aber daran hat sich auch etwas geändert
das hat sich zum Beispiel in der
Finanzkrise geändert als die
weltbeobachten konnte dass wir selber in
zwanken geraten sind und nicht mehr so
erfolgreich waren und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass liberale Demokratie auch
erfolgschuldet deshalb müssen wir bei
der planungsbeschleunigung Tempo machen
und deshalb bin ich stolz darauf dass
der kleine bescheidene Beitrag den wir
leisten können als Rechtspolitik dass
wir ihn als erstes geleistet haben mit
einem Entwurf zur Reform der
Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung um ein
Beschleunigungsgebot im deutschen
Rechtssystem sicherzustellen um die
Energiewende schnell voranzubringen und
um Infrastrukturprojekte schnell
voranzubringen wir schulden Erfolg
und ich will sagen
das gilt natürlich auch für die Nutzung
der Digitalisierung da geht es auch um
die Akzeptanz des Rechtsstaates die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die heute in
ihren Dienstleistungsberufen digital
arbeiten die ein Streaming-Dienst in
wenigen Minuten buchen die wollen nicht
den Eindruck haben dass die Justiz wie
im letzten Jahrhundert arbeitet und
deshalb finde ich es richtig dass wir
uns dahinter klemmen dass der Staat
digital wird Digitalisierung ist nicht
napolar Digitalisierung steht im Dienste
der Bürger und deshalb ist
Digitalisierung Dienst an der Demokratie
und an der Akzeptanz des Rechtsstaat
meine Freundinnen und Freunde meine
lieben Damen und Herren und deshalb will
ich einen sagen
und komme damit auch zum Schluss wenn
uns ein Mangel an Engagement dort
vorgeworfen wird dann will ich darauf
hinweisen dass Bundesministerium der
Justiz führt von vorne wir haben die
Einführung der elektronischen Akte
abgeschlossen wir beginnen mit der
Einführung des elektronischen Workflows
alle Gerichte und Behörden meines
Geschäftsbereichs werden vermutlich im
nächsten Jahr die akteneinführung
abgeschlossen haben viele haben es schon
getan wenn man einen digitalisierten
Gerichtssaal sich anschauen will gehe
zum bundespatentamt nach zum
Bundespatentgericht nach München wir
machen Tempo bei der Digitalisierung und
das ist wichtig denn wir schulden Erfolg
zu Akzeptanz unserer Demokratie
herzlichen Dank meine Damen
Marco Buschmann übrigens ganz ohne
Manuskript mit Ausführungen zur rechts-
und Sicherheitspolitik und deren Grenzen
in einer parlamentarischen Demokratie er
sagt in einer liberalen Demokratie die
Gegenrede bzw die Sicht der AFD folgt
von Tobias Matthias Becker
Minister sehr geehrte Kollegen es wurde
bereits wie gesagt diese Woche zu diesem
übermäßig
aufgeblähten Bundeshaushalt über den wir
hier im weitesten Sinne Herr Buschmann
diskutieren historisch sind auch
eigentlich die Haushalte der Hebel um
übergriffige Regierungen an die Kandare
zu legen aber naja hier in dem Haus wird
das so schnell nicht passieren der
spatenhaushalt Justiz kommt jedenfalls
unaufgeregt daher erst klein erst
technokratisch oder finanziert sich zum
Teil sogar noch selbst eine Art
schutzbiotop könnte man meinen in diesen
aus den Fugen geratenen Zeiten aber auch
hier leistet sich die ampelregierung das
ein oder andere Pflänzchen das einfach
sinnfrei ist das Forum rechts zum
Beispiel es wurde schon erwähnt mit
Heeren Worten und Zielen in die Welt
gesetzt ist weitgehend inaktiv bzw
bespaßt nur den Elfenbeinturm der
sogenannten Experten
wir fordern schon lange die Abschaffung
davon die Ziele die man dort aufführt
die können auch wirklich besser
adressiert werden also unterstehen Sie
sich bitte gleich als Replik wieder etwa
die billigste aller Keulen auszupacken
wir würden den Nationalsozialismus und
sein Unrecht etwa nicht ernst nehmen
sowas glaubt ihnen zwischen nicht mal
mehr ihre kernwählerschaft
ich
ich erwähne auch immer wieder wie froh
ich eigentlich bin dass das
Justizministerium nicht in den Klauen
der SPD oder der Grünen ist eigentlich
aber ganz ehrlich irgendwie kommt
einfach keine eigene Handschrift von
Herrn Buschmann wo sind die Initiativen
die ein bisschen eigenes Profil erkennen
lassen selbst der digitalpakt von
Rechtsstaat war und ist ein Gebirge und
das noch alles andere als sicher selbst
Frau Lambrecht hat in der letzten
Legislatur ein stimmigeres politisches
Konzept gehabt und das will wirklich was
heißen
in Corona Dingen in Corona Dingen durfte
eben Herr Lauterbach machen was er
wollte bei wirtschaftlichen Aspekten kam
der Einsatzbefehl direkt von Vizekanzler
Habeck Schützenhilfe aus dem
Finanzministerium nicht mal das für
Herrn Buschmann und von der
Königsdisziplin der ampelregierung der
der diversity allumfassende Geltung bei
uns zu verschaffen natürlich ganz zu
schweigen da geht das Justizministerium
sowieso brav den bekannten Koryphäen
einfach nur zur Hand passend konkret im
Haushalt schlägt sich das z.B bei der
halben Million für hate nieder die ja
noch gegen die FDP hineingerutscht sind
absolute politische Schlagseite ist hier
zu erwarten von dieser Organisation wie
es sich bisher auch immer gezeigt hat
immerhin sehr zu begrüßen Unterstützung
für verarmte Holocaust Überlebende in
Israel wurde ja nicht erwähnt da hätte
das auch übrigens noch ein bisschen mehr
sein können zumindest wenn dafür der den
beiden Turm vor dem recht gefallen wäre
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Dirk Wiese das Wort und er ist einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
SPD-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sehr geehrter Minister Buschmann lieber
Günter Krings ich bin Ihnen sehr dankbar
dass sie ihre Redezeit dafür verwendet
haben vielleicht eine generelle
Aussprache über die Rechtspolitik bis
zum heutigen Tage auch durchzuführen und
ich will diesen diesen Ball auch gerne
aufgreifen und ich glaube in der
heutigen Debatte bei vielen Beiträgen
nicht bei allen wird noch mal deutlich
wie wichtig gerade in diesen Zeiten ein
funktionierender Rechtsstaat ist auf dem
man sich verlassen kann der funktioniert
und der gerade auch letztendlich dafür
sorgt dass das Recht bei uns im Land
auch durchgesetzt wird und das ist
glaube ich etwas und die Justizminister
Buschmann hat es angesprochen wenn wir
gerade uns international anschauen wenn
wir uns schauen den völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
wenn wir sehen wie Recht in anderen
Staaten missbraucht wird wenn wir sehen
wie in anderen Staaten
auch in Frage gestellt wird wenn wir uns
auch anschauen wie in europäischen
Staaten die Mitglied in der Europäischen
Union sind wenn ich gerade auch nach
Ungarn schaue Rechtsstaat eigentlich
nicht mehr funktioniert dann ist es
wichtig in dieser Debatte deutlich zu
machen auch wenn es der kleinste Etat
ist den wir heute beraten dass es gut
ist dass wir bei uns in diesem Land
diesen funktionierenden Rechtsstaat
haben und wir diesen funktionierenden
Rechtsstaat mit diesem Haushalt auch
unterstützen
und es ist auch wichtig noch einmal
darauf hinzuweisen dass es richtig ist
dass ich auch die Bundesrepublik
rechtsstaatlichen Initiativen anschlägt
auch international dem Recht zur
Durchsetzung verhelfen will und ich will
das noch mal sagen es ist gut dass wir
auch als ampelregierung als
Bundesregierung ein klares Zeichen jetzt
noch mal gesetzt haben sehr geehrter
Herr Minister gegen die Todesstrafe wo
im Iran gerade Menschen für die Freiheit
auf die Straße gehen Menschen dafür zu
Tode verurteilt werden weil sie in
Freiheit leben wollen das ist ein gutes
Zeichen dass wir hier klar Farbe
bekennen die Todesstrafe darf nicht sein
und wir müssen unsere Stimme da erheben
wo das Recht gebeugt wird und wo das
Recht mit Füßen getreten wird
und ich will auch sagen weil es ein
Projekt der letzte großen Koalition
gewesen ist was die SPD vorangebracht
hat der Pakt für den Rechtsstaat ist
richtig und wichtig aber und das muss
doch auch selbstverständlich sein die
Gelder die wir im Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat zur Verfügung stellen die
wir jetzt auch zur Verfügung stellen für
den digitalen Pakt für den Rechtsstaat
wir wollen doch dass diese Mittel auch
dafür verwendet werden den Rechtsstaat
zu stärken es muss doch möglich sein
dass uns die Bundesländer auch ganz klar
sagen wofür diese Mittel verwendet
werden dass die Mittel auch
zielgerichtet ankommen und ich bin schon
manchmal erstaunt dass wenn auch
nachgefragt wird wofür werden denn die
Mittel verwendet zum Beispiel in Bayern
in Baden-Württemberg keine Antwort kommt
und deshalb ist es richtig genau
hinzuschauen sich genau einen Eindruck
zu verschaffen wenn wir das hinbekommen
gemeinsam mit den Ländern gemeinsam mit
dem Bundesjustizministerium mit den
Haushältern im Haushaltsausschuss dann
wird auch dieser Pakt für den digitalen
Rechtsstaat funktionieren wir stehen
jedenfalls dazu dass diese Gelder auch
ankommen und dafür verwendet werden
wofür sie vorgesehen
Liebe Kollege Krings sie haben es gerade
angesprochen so ein bisschen als wir
hier Rechtspolitik machen wollen nach
gut dünken dass wir Rechtspolitik machen
sollen mit Vorhaben die sie nicht ganz
nachvollziehen können ich will das mal
ein bisschen vergleichen es war eine
sozialliberale Koalition in den 70er
Jahren die erste Rechtspolitik dazu
wieder verhelfen musste das
Lebensrealitäten anerkannt werden würden
und heute ist es doch genauso ihre Rede
hat manchmal den Eindruck als sie zurück
wollen in die 50er Jahre wir wollen
gesellschaftspolitisch nicht das Rad
zurückgeben wir wollen nicht zurück in
die 50er wir wollen jetzt eine moderne
Rechtspolitik die Lebensrealitäten
anerkennt nicht nur sozialliberal
sondern mit grüner Unterstützung das
wird diese Ampelkoalition voranbringen
das erkennt Lebensrealitäten an und wenn
ich dann die Proteste von ganz rechts
höre dann muss ich natürlich sagen wer
schon Probleme hat mit der Verfassung
der sollte am heutigen Tage in dieser
Debatte tatsächlich lieber schweigen und
sich erstmal das ein oder andere soll
Gemüte führt
wir haben weitere Punkte vereinbart in
diese Ampelkoalition die wir
voranbringen wollen und ich will sagen
dass viele der Punkte die da stehen
wichtig sind die jetzt auch mit Elan
anzugehen wir haben viele gute Punkte in
diesem Koalitionsvertrag hinein für
andere gilt gerade im Bereich des
sozialen Mietrechts weil wir schon
feststellen dass die Situation gerade
für viele Mieterinnen und Mieter
schwierig ist dass sie eine schwierige
Situation gerade in den Ballungszentren
haben aber mittlerweile auch in den
ländlichen Raum in die Kleinstädte
hinein darum wollen wir die Projekte
zügig voranbringen die wir im Mietrecht
im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben
und wir brauchen auch
Handlungsspielräume für unsere Kommunen
und darum ist es wichtig und da werden
wir als SPD auch nicht locker lassen
dass wir auch das kommunale
Vorkaufsrecht voranbringen das brauchen
die Kommunen vor Ort das wird gebraucht
und da wird wir auf den nötigen Druck
jetzt machen dass das auch ebenfalls
voran gebracht wird und das geht auch in
die richtige Richtung und ich will auch
sagen dass es richtig ist dass wir
Projekte schon vorangebracht haben die
auch gezeigt haben dass diese
Ampelkoalition auch mit Sachen die
bisher nicht möglich waren Sie
voranbringen ich erinnere noch mal an
die Abschaffung des 219a des
strafsgesetzbuch auch das war ein
wichtiges Signal was die Ampelkoalition
im ersten Jahr auf den Weg gebracht hat
und ich will auch sagen dass es richtig
gewesen ist dass die Ampelkoalition das
Wählen mit 16 bei der Europawahl möglich
gemacht hat und genauso gut werden wir
dafür streiten dass wählen mit 16 auch
bei der Bundestagswahl möglich
[Applaus]
ist und in junge Leute wir glauben dass
junge Leute verantwortlich damit handeln
können und wir glauben nicht dass
jedenfalls der Ansatz der von rechts und
von der Union vertreten wird an diesem
Punkt glaube ich der Richtige ist und
von daher diese Ampelkoalition wirkt in
der Rechtspolitik wir wollen was
voranbringen wir wollen zeigen was geht
und sehr geehrter Herr Krings wenn ich
mich da noch mal an die große Koalition
der Rückkehrerinnen weil sie gerade
sozusagen den Rechtsbereich das sehr
gelobt haben ich erinnere mich sehr gut
an die Zeit zurück sie waren ja da im
Innenministerium das Justizministerium
hat sehr oft gezeigt was geht was
möglich ist wo wir vorankommen wollen
und ihre Meinung war immer das geht
nicht machen wir nicht wollen wir nicht
tun wir nicht mit uns nicht zu machen
das war Politik die jetzt nicht mehr
möglich ist wir werden da anders
vorangehen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
am Schluss noch ein wenig
Vergangenheitsbewältigung aus der Zeit
der großen Koalition von Dirk Wiese in
Richtung Günther Krings aus der
Unionsfraktion der nächste Redner jetzt
hier am Pult kommt auch aus der
Unionsfraktion speziell aus der CSU
Landesgruppe ist Sprecher für
Verbraucherschutzpolitik und heißt Volk
Karl Ulrich
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
das Gesamtvolumen des Bundeshaushalts
beträgt 476 Milliarden Euro
allein
45,6 Milliarden Euro netto
Kreditaufnahme sind zu verzeichnen ein
Haushalt
der ordentlich im Volumen ist und umso
enttäuschender ist dann dass im Bereich
der Rechtspolitik zu wenig übrig
geblieben ist sie haben im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart dass sie
den Pakt für den Rechtsstaat verstetigen
wollen und ihn erweitern um einen
digitalen Pakt für den Rechtsstaat das
sind zwei packte mit diesem
Haushaltsentwurf
konterkarieren sie aber ihren eigenen
Koalitionsvertrag und enttäuschen das
Vertrauen das in diesen Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat auch von Zeiten der Länder
gesetzt worden ist nämlich das durch den
Bund eine ordentliche Mittelausstattung
erfolgt und dass damit die Justiz
digitalisiert und ordentlich personell
ausgestattet wird ist mit den 200
Millionen Euro auf vier Jahre nicht
erfüllt sie haben damit eine Chance
vertan es ist zu wenig
Herr Minister buschmann
sie haben über den furchtbaren
schrecklichen angriffskriegs Russlands
auf die Ukraine gesprochen auch über die
juristische Aufarbeitung
es ist gut dass sie als
Justizminister in Kiew fahren und das
auch die G7 sich mit der Frage der
juristischen Aufarbeitung
auseinandersetzen wird der Punkt ist
aber
angesichts der Größe des Verbrechens und
der großen juristischen Frage wie wir
Kriegsverbrechen habhaft werden
auch durch die Anklage des Verbrechens
der Aggression darf es nicht allein bei
runden bleiben und bei gegenseitigen
Besuchen sondern wir brauchen eine klare
Haltung der Bundesregierung diese
Kriegsverbrechen auch Anklagen zu können
und abgeurteilt zu sehen deswegen bitte
ich sie nochmal dass sich unsere
Initiative anschließen durch ein
Sondertribunal deutlich zu machen diese
Verbrechen müssen zeitnah abgeurteilt
werden ein Sondertribunal ist
unvermeidlich
und unvermeidlich ist auch dass wir den
Schutz der Schwächsten in der
Gesellschaft adressieren es geht um die
Frage wie wir
Opfer von Missbrauch helfen dadurch dass
diese Straftaten entdeckt aufgeklärt und
abgeurteilt werden es geht auch um die
Frage wie wir die schlimmsten Verbrechen
in der Rechtsgemeinschaft Mord sexual
Missbrauch Vergewaltigung
raubmethodesfolge aufklären
und ja
es gibt einen Urteil jetzt auch das
Europäischen
Gerichtshofs und weitere Rechtsverfahren
die bei der Speicherung von verbindungs-
aber es sind nicht nur Grenzen gesetzt
worden sondern die Gerichte haben auch
Möglichkeiten aufgezeigt
und die Möglichkeiten die aufgezeigt
wurden sind mehr als nur klickfries
selbst die bundesinnenministerin nennt
sie Feser sagt ich darf sie zitieren
quick Fries ist kein adäquater Ersatz
für die Speicherung von IP-Adressen
deswegen möchte ich dass sie im
Interesse auch der Missbrauchsopfer die
auf Aufklärung und auf Aburteilung der
schlimmsten Täter hoffen dass Sie hier
einen sprechenden abgestimmten
Gesetzentwurf einbringen der mehr als
quickfries ist der auf der Höhe der
Kriminalpolitik ist
und
in diesem Zusammenhang kann ich das
nicht ersparen
man kann sich bei der Frage der
Speicherung der IP-Adressen
unterschiedlich über die Grenzen
austauschen
und über die Verfassungsmäßigkeit der
ein oder anderen Frage trefflich
streiten
aber bei diesem Thema bei allem Respekt
verbieten sich China Vergleiche ja gar
die Erwähnung das ist was völlig anderes
es hat in einer rechtsstaatlichen
Debatte nichts zu suchen
meine Damen und Herren ja die liberale
Demokratie und die liberale Ordnung wird
angegriffen oder zumindest von einigen
Frage gestellt
und die Antwort darauf lautet auch
Rechtsstaat und Rechtsstaatlichkeit das
bedeutet für uns aber in der
Gesetzgebung und auch beim
justizhaushalt dass wir klar und mit
Vernunft die Fragen der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit debattieren und dass
wir der Versuchung widerstehen
durch
gesellschaftliche verlockende auch
populistische Konzepte dieser großen
Aufgabe nicht gerecht zu werden deswegen
meine Damen und Herren geht es um gute
rechtschätzung und um ein klares
Bekenntnis zur Stärke des Rechtsstaats
Fraktion hat noch mal verwiesen auf
einen dezent-szenen ist in der Koalition
gibt in Sachen Vorratsdatenspeicherung
da hatte der Europäische Gerichtshof ja
die Regelung in Deutschland gekippt im
September 22 jetzt ringt die Koalition
um einen Nachfolgemodell da sind sich
der Bundesjustizminister und die
bundesinnenministerin die ganz einig wie
ist denn tatsächlich mal aussehen soll
Steffen ist der nächste Redner aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
statt zu verstetigen und ein digitalpakt
für die Justiz zu errichten wir haben im
Haushalt jetzt die Voraussetzungen
geschaffen für einen Einstieg in den
digitalpakt für die Justiz Pakt setzt
natürlich voraus dass man sich
vernünftig vereinbart das gilt dann für
beide Seiten insoweit ist auch richtig
da genau hinzugucken wasserländer
seitlich gemacht wird voraussetzung ist
dass man sich vernünftig vereinbart der
zweite Teil die Verstetigung des Pakt zu
den Rechtsstaat ist ein Vorhaben was im
Koalitionsvertrag dessen Umsetzung noch
hart und dass wir auch natürlich dann
noch dringend angehen müssen und
natürlich ja wenn man sich diesen Thema
widmet natürlich wird auch ein Pakt für
den Rechtsstaat der nicht
notwendigerweise eins zu eins sozusagen
hat wie das in der Vergangenheit war
sich stark mit Themen der
Digitalisierung beschäftigen müssen
und das ist auch notwendig ist ja eine
vielbeachtete Studie veröffentlicht
worden von der buzzeros Law School hat
man verglichen wo stehen wir denn
eigentlich bei der Digitalisierung der
Justiz und tatsächlich ist der
Ausgangspunkt dieser Koalition das
Deutschland anderen Staaten die sich
schon länger bemühen 10 bis 15 Jahre bei
der Digitalisierung hinterher hängt und
wenn wir jetzt modernisieren dann ist es
natürlich nicht alleine ausreichend weil
es kommt ja dann darauf an dass wir
diesen Vorsprung aufholen das heißt wir
müssen in der Innovation schneller
werden und dürfen nicht den Abstand
größer werden lassen und deswegen müssen
wir natürlich auch eine andere Form von
Innovation an den Tag legen gerade
deswegen brauchen wir große Ressourcen
von Bund und Ländern um das als
gemeinsamen Prozess auch hinzukriegen
und das muss auch tatsächlich in
vertrauensvoller Zusammenarbeit
gemeinsam entwickeln werden
und das ist so wichtig weil natürlich
die Frage ob die Lebensrealität die die
Menschen erleben auch irgendwas zu tun
hat mit der Realität die bei Gericht
erlebt wird wenn das zu weit
auseinanderfällt dann leidet die
Akzeptanz des Rechts und dann ist das
ein Angriff auch auf die Resilienz des
Rechtsstaats weil die Leute ihre
Probleme dann vielleicht anders lösen
und an der Stelle muss ich ganz klar
sagen wer hier in diesem Debatten mit
Schuldzuweisungen Arbeit ist Teil des
Problems wir müssen das gemeinsam
hinkriegen und deswegen ist es nicht
ausreichend zu sagen es ist super dass
wir soweit sind dass bei den
Bundesgerichten die Akte eingeführt ist
aber natürlich kann der Befunden erst
dann zufriedenstellen wenn wir sagen
können alle Gerichte bei Bund und
Ländern sind soweit und auch da muss der
Bund ein Auge drauf haben dass das
tatsächlich am Ende gelingt es gibt zwei
wichtige Voraussetzungen für das was
jetzt kommt die Aktie ist ja nur
Voraussetzung für eine effektive
Digitalisierung die Akte ist ja nur ein
Schritt der tatsächlich schon längst
hätte folgen müssen dass versprochen ist
jetzt die Verabredung darüber was kommt
eigentlich als nächster Schritt und wie
kommen wir wirklich zu einer wirklich
durchgreifenden Digitalisierung und da
will ich nur zwei Voraussetzungen nennen
erstens es reicht nicht aus dass wir
einfach analoge Prozesse die so
entstanden sind weil wir in der
Vergangenheit mit Papier gearbeitet
haben dass man die ins digitale
überträgt sondern wir müssen noch die
Prozesse verändern und bislang machen
wir tatsächlich nur diese Übertragung
von analogen Prozesse ins digitale da
müssen wir ganz anderen Ansatz an die
Digitalisierung gewinnen und das zweite
ist tatsächlich dass wir Prozesse von
Anfang bis Ende denken müssen da will
ich nur ein kleines Beispiel nennen in
Hamburg haben die Gerichtsvollzieher
jetzt tatsächlich die elektronische Akte
zur Verfügung und sind letztlich
wundersame Fügung zuständig für alle
pfändungs- und beweisungsbeschlüsse die
bei der Postbank einzureichen sind
bundesweit das führt dazu dass das
elektronisch eingeht beim
Gerichtsvollzieher da aber alles
ausgedruckt werden muss und jeden Tag
ein Lieferwagen zu Niederlassung der
Postbank fährt das ist tatsächlich
wirklich etwas was nicht funktioniert
und wo auch ich denn das
Bundesjustizministerium in der
Verantwortung sehe dafür zu sorgen dass
solche Prozesse von Anfang bis Ende
digitalisiert stattfinden auch wenn
Player aus anderen
Zuständigkeitsbereichen hier einen
Beitrag leisten müssen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
der Abgeordnete Stefan Brandner für die
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir beschließen unter diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt heute über zwei
Einzelpläne die von ja nicht gerade
finanzieller Tragweite und daher
finanziell gesehen eher unbedeutend sind
zum einen beschließen wir bei den
Haushalt des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
da steht da dran interessanterweise hat
dazu bisher niemand was gesagt wir
können ich kann die Spannung lösen also
die von der AFD werden diesem Einzelplan
zustimmen und das zustimmen und unter
trotz des unglücklichen Wirkung des
Gerichts unter seinem zweifelhaften
Präsidenten habe der inzwischen alles
das bestätigt hat was vorher nur
Vorurteile waren Stichwort
ich habe gerade weiter gedacht Stichwort
mangelnde Distanz zu den Regierenden
Stichwort fragwürdige
Medienberichterstattung dieser elitäre
Zirkel der in Karlsruhe da ins Leben
gerufen wurde man muss feststellen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
Ähnlichkeiten mit der Männer Fußball
Nationalmannschaft viele viele
Jahrzehnte geachtete erfolgreiche
unangefochtene respektable Institution
inzwischen leider in Folge ideologischer
Verbindungen Ausrichtung Meilen weiter
davon entfernt nur noch kleine Schatten
ihrer selbst dieser kleine Stadt an
ihrer selbst das gilt auch für das
Bundesjustizministerium der Kollege
Kriegs hatte darauf hingewiesen weiland
war das Justizministerium das Zentrum
der Gesetzgebung in Deutschland seit
vielen Jahren wirkt es leider nur noch
wie eine woke wie eine woge-propaganda
Abteilung von kleinen Parteien erst
geführt von mutmaßlichen SPD
Lamprecht ihre Schwerpunkte bei
Grundgesetz Schwier Zensurpolitik
gesehen haben inzwischen geleitet von
Marco Buschmann der Gott sei Dank muss
man sagen trotz seiner hunderten von
Juristen im Ministerium bislang kaum
etwas zustande bekommen hat aber ganz
viele schlimme Sachen offenbar ausbrütet
ich denke da an die
strafgesetzbuchreform die durchs Land
schwebt ich denke an den Unsinn
Elternteil 1 Elternteil zwei Mutter eins
Mutter zwei ich denke an den bereits
umgesetzten uns in der Cannabis
Legalisierung das ist ja unmittelbar
davor das verstehe ich sogar noch aus
Richtung des Kollegen Lauterbach ich
verstehe es allerdings nicht dass die
FDP sich davor so einen linken unfugszug
spannen lässt und das mitmacht es sei
denn man sagt tatsächlich ihre links rot
grüne Politik ist nur im Rausch zu
ertragen meine Damen und Herren
Steuermittel an zwielichtige
Institutionen verschleudert werden wie
die amadeo antonio-stiftung die Magnus
hirschverstiftung daran haben wir uns
gewöhnt dass allerdings ein Grund warum
wir diesen Haushalt diesen Einzelplan 07
des Bundesjustizministeriums ablehnen
ablehnen auch deshalb weil sich ein
Pinocchio Politiker an die Spitze des
ministeriumsgesetz hat der Buschmann sie
sind ursprünglich mal angetreten mit dem
Spruch das KODi corona-maßnahmen müssen
ein absolutes Ende haben im März 2022
das Gegenteil haben sie gemacht sie
haben Paragraph 28b des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes eingefügt noch
immer drangsalien und schikanieren sie
draußen die Bürger noch immer wird
darauf hingewiesen dass ein immer eine
Impfpflicht eine einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht besteht am Ende dieser
Impfpflicht fangen jetzt übrigens in
Thüringen an die Städte in Jena
beispielsweise Bußgeldbescheide zu
verschicken an diejenigen die sie auch
Überzeugung nicht haben impfen lassen
das ist schäbige Pinocchio Politik die
sie bisher in diesem Jahr abgeliefert
haben
hochladen 07 vielen Dank
der Bundestag diskutiert über den
Einzelplan 07 das ist der des
bundesjustizministers und den Einzelplan
19 das ist der Etat für das
Bundesverfassungsgericht und in dieser
Debatte spricht jetzt Margit Cara
armetolo aus der SPD-Fraktion das ist
übrigens die Stunde der Juristen und
Rechtsanwälte
Herr Minister Buschmann werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren ich möchte eine der Förderungen
im Einzelplan 07 zum Ausgangspunkt
meiner Rede machen nämlich die
Unterstützung der gemeinnützigen GmbH
mit 497 000 Euro bereits der Kollege
Brune höhnel hat die Arbeit von hay Date
in seine Rede hervorgehoben es ist gut
dass dieser Zuschuss der im
Ursprungsentwurf nicht vorgesehen war
noch hinein verhandelt wurde wir konnten
für die wichtige Arbeit die dort
geleistet wird sogar noch etwas
drauflegen im vergangenen Haushalt lag
die Förderung noch bei 350.000 Euro
weshalb ich das heraus als Rechtsanwalt
habe ich nicht nur immer wieder
Opfer von Gewalttaten vertreten ich
hatte auch Spezial mit dem Bereich der
digitalen Gewalt ständige
Berührungspunkte mein Fachbereich ist
das Urheber und Medienrecht in dieser
Funktion habe ich Fälle bearbeitet in
dem intimste Bild und Videoaufnahmen von
Menschen unerlaubt veröffentlicht wurden
die sozialen und die seelischen Folgen
solcher bildbasierten sexualisierten
Gewalttaten kann man mit Worten gar
nicht beschreiben hätte hat ein
großartiges Beratungsangebot für
Betroffene digitale Gewalt geschaffen
und unterstützt die Opfer auch bei
möglichen Prozesskosten sie klären auf
über die vielschichtigen Formen
digitaler Gewalt geben Hilfe bis ins
kleinste Detail zum Beispiel erklären
sie wie man im Fall eines Online
Angriffs einen rechtssicheren Screenshot
erstellt und hält arbeitet politisch
bringt also auf immer bessere Lösungen
für die Opfer digitaler Gewalt was für
uns Politikerinnen und Politiker
mitunter nicht immer angenehm ist
denn es gibt Bereiche ich komme noch
dazu da hinken wir unseren Ansprüchen
noch hinterher hält aid hat
Vorbildcharakter die Erfolgsgeschichten
vor Gericht sind immer häufiger sichtbar
und deshalb ist es gute und richtig dass
unser justizeter hier weiterhin eine
Förderung vorsieht
meine Damen und Herren Werte Kollegen
und Kollegen
zahlreiche Studien benennen es ganz klar
von digitaler Gewalt sind vor allem
Frauen und Mädchen betroffen die
Angriffe auf Frauen und Mädchen sie
ziehen in der Regel auf das Geschlecht
ab oder sind beleidigend und bedrohend
mit sexuelle Komponente eine übliche
Reaktion auf digitale Gewalt ist sich
aus den entsprechenden Foren und
Plattformen zurückzuziehen sich solchen
Attacken entziehen zu wollen dass es
sicher
nachvollziehbar zugleicherweise seine
verheerende gesellschaftliche
Entwicklung denn unsere Demokratie
braucht auch im digitalen Raum den
offenen Austausch in einem sicheren
Rahmen und deshalb müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass sich die Menschen in den
sozialen Medien sicher fühlen meine
Damen und Herren werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Hass und Hetze im Netz sind gnadenlos so
wurde diesen Sommer die österreichische
Ärztin Lisa Marie Kellermeier durch Hatz
und Hetze regelrecht in den Tod
getrieben sie hatte sich trotz
Beleidigungen und Drohungen nicht
zurückgezogen und auf Twitter
corona-maßnahmen wie die Impfung
verteidigt mit den immer krasserwerten
den Anfeindungen musste sie weitgehend
alleine fertig werden sie versuchte noch
ihre Praxis gegen Querdenker abzusichern
die sich ja teilweise als Patienten
getan näherten um sie dann verweise zu
attackieren am Ende aber am Ende fehlte
ihr die Kraft sich weiter zu wehren sie
gab ihre Praxis auf und nahm sich
schließlich das Leben sowas macht einen
wirklich sprachlos und deutlicher kann
man es nicht aufzeigen virtuelle Hass
trifft immer echte nicht virtuelle
Menschen und deshalb
möchte ich diesen Haushaltsentwurf der
ja auch den Bereich der Digitalisierung
im Fokus hat für einen Appell nutzen
lassen sie uns mehr tun gegen digitale
Gewalt und wo sie doch passiert lassen
Sie uns die Opfer tatkräftiger
unterstützen meine Damen und Herren
Werte Kollegen und Kollegen
es gibt dafür ja viele
gute oft heißt es auch dass Beton zum
Beispiel auch hate dass es viel weniger
an den Gesetzen als der Durchsetzung
dieser Gesetze haben hat mit dem vor
einer Woche in Kraft getretenen digital
Service der EU haben wir erstmals
EU-weit verbindliche Pflichten für alle
Anbieter digitale Dienste
illegale Inhalte schneller zu entfernen
und die Grundrechte von Nutzerinnen und
Nutzer zu schützen und gleichwohl gilt
das Gesetz erst ab Februar 2024 und
vielleicht schaffen wir es ja in
Deutschland noch vorher ein paar mehr
Dinge anzuschieben sowohl der
Koalitionsvertrag als auch die in
Meseberg verabschiedete
digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung
bieten dafür eine gute Grundlage viele
Ideen liegen ja bereits vor zum Beispiel
ein Gesetz gegen digitale Gewalt mit dem
wir rechtliche Hürden für Betroffene
abbauen elektronische Verfahren zur
Anzeigenerstattung oder eben auch
richterlich angeordnete Account sperren
werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen
Sie uns gemeinsam diese Projekte schnell
in die Tat umsetzen und der virtuellen
Gewalt im Netz ganz reale handfeste
Grenzen aufzeigen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
SPD-Fraktion unter anderem mit einem der
besonders tragischen Fälle die aus
digital verbreiteten Hassbotschaften
resultierten eine die seit Jahren die
vor Gericht gegen solche Hassbotschaften
kämpft und schon häufig recht bekommen
hat ist Renate Künast
und Kollegen ich muss einen Satz vorab
zum Kollegen Frings sagen wissen Sie
sie haben recht sorry das waren
Versprecher Herr Krings
als wir hier angefangen haben als
Regierung hat es eigentlich nichts
gegeben sie haben in dem Bereich
Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu Sicherung von
Daten zugänglich machen so viel in den
letzten Jahren getan sind aber immer vor
gerichtswende gelaufen ob beim
Europäischen Gerichtshof oder beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht und dass sie
dann jetzt hier so tun als hätten sie
die Weisheit mit Löffeln gefressen Herr
Kollege grins finde ich schon eine tolle
Nummer wir sie wissen genau dass auch
der EU europäische gesichtshof von
anders bezogen redet ich weiß nicht wie
sie hier im Saal Anlass bezogen ihre
Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen wollen
für ihren für ihren Bereich sie sind
schon wieder auf hoher See an der Stelle
und ich sage Ihnen was wir machen
nachdem sie 16 Jahre lang immer versucht
haben nie umgesetzt haben und leere
Blätter hinterlassen haben wir haben
jetzt einen rechts sicheren entworfen
der wird uns helfen darum geht
und jetzt soll ich noch mal zur
Grundsatzfrage kommen zu Demokratie und
Rechtsstaat die im Augenblick wirklich
herausgefordert sind da haben ja einige
was zugesagt ich muss sie mal sagen
Demokratie und Rechtsstaat steht im
Augenblick unter einem massiven Druck
auch weil wir nicht nur die analoge Welt
haben sondern weil in der digitalen Welt
einige das digitale die Stimmungsmache
die Herabwürdigung und hate speech death
Informationen und Fake News und Fake
Zitate gnadenlos ausnutzen und zwar
systematisch ausnutzen weil sie diese
Demokratie zerstören wollen und den
rechter und das ist unsere Aufgabe
dagegen zu halten meine Damen und Herren
und wir erleben das in vielen Bereichen
wir leben das aus dem Bereich
Rechtsextremismus wir leben erleben das
bei Trump beim brexit das Leute mit viel
Geld ob sie oder viel Interessen ob sie
nun in St Petersburg sitzen oder
irgendwo in den USA versuchen
demokratische Strukturen zu zerstören
Demokratie zu zerstören und ein brexit
also ein Zerbrechen auch der
Europäischen Union zu betreiben meine
Damen und Herren und genau darum geht es
dass wir dagegen halten und ich glaube
dass wir in diesem Haushalt ein paar
wirklich gute Elemente dazu haben
Elemente um dagegen zu halten das Forum
recht haben hier einige
das Forum recht haben wir einige
kritisiert bei manchen verstehe ich auch
warum weil sie nämlich Angst haben dass
ihre orchestrierten Strategien nicht
aufgehen ich finde schade dass wir da
Geld da gesperrt haben wie es dazu kommt
was sie selber falsch gemacht haben weil
sie nicht aber ich denke wir werden das
beseitigen weil wir eines brauchen die
Diskussion über das Recht über
Demokratie wie das gestaltet ist wie die
Prozesse sind und wie man darüber dass
tatsächlich umsetzen kann und als
Bürgerinnen und Bürger selber
mitgestalten kann das brauchen wir
deshalb brauchen wir das Forum recht und
ich sage Ihnen wir ich finde es auch gut
dass am Ende doch noch hate eine
Finanzierung bekommen hat für die
digitale Beratung meine Damen und Herren
warum weil ob individuelles Mobbing oder
orchestrierte rechtsextreme
Vorgehensweisen mit dem Ziel Menschen
rauszutreiben aus dem aus dem Netz und
aus der demokratischen Teilhabe da
müssen wir was gegenhalten und lassen
Sie mich ein letzten
sie an ihren Kollegen unsere an dieser
Stelle würde ich ein eines sagen wir
wollen das Geschäftsmodell dieser
Dienste einschränken das ist so nicht
akzeptabel wir werden Rechtsextremismus
uns gegen werden und wir sind erst am
Anfang nachdem in diesem Haushalt meine
Damen und Herren wird auch ein digitales
Gewaltschutzgesetz kommen müssen und
zwar bitte bald Herr Minister
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen die seit
Jahren gegen sogenannten hate speech
gegen Hassbotschaften aller Art und auf
allen Kanälen kämpft vor Gericht und da
auch häufig schon recht bekommen hat
Elisabeth winkelmeier-becker ist die
nächste Rednerin aus der Union Fraktion
gehört dieser debat
te Teil ist der kleinste Haushalt
roundabout eine Milliarde aber das
spiegelt nicht wieder welche Bedeutung
und auch nicht welche Kosten die Justiz
verursacht und die getragen werden denn
die Länder die Bundesländer tragen hier
den Löwenanteil mit etwa 15 Milliarden
Euro und das zusammen ist dann doch auch
schon vergleichbar mit anderen
bundeshaushalten die eben hauptsächlich
aus dem Bund finanziert werden und mehr
auch mit Geld ausgeben handeln als wir
wir haben einen direkten
Verwaltungshaushalt schwerpunktmäßig
rechts und Justiz das ist gemeinsame
Aufgabe von Hund und Ländern und deshalb
ist der Pakt für Justiz Fakt für den
Rechtsstaat so wichtig der hier heute
auch schon angesprochen worden ist sie
haben versprochen den vorzusetzen und um
die digitalkomponente vor allem auch zu
erweitern das muss gelingen E-Akte ist
angesprochen worden die
Digitalisierung von verzeich da warten
viele Praktika drauf all das muss
gelingen sonst wäre ein Scheitern für
uns alle schlimm und das ist sicherlich
ein Unterschied ob man ein einzelnes
Patentgericht digitalisiert das kann man
schaffen aber es ist ein Unterschied ob
man hunderte von Gerichten im ganzen
Land digitalisieren musste ist der
Finanzaufwand nicht vergleichbar und da
sind wir noch lange lange nicht fertig
hierfür brauchen die Länder mehr
Unterstützung
und sie ja Justizminister haben in
diesen Tagen
Gesetzentwürfe vorgelegt zur
Digitalisierung oder zur Aufzeichnung
auch der Verhandlungen in Zivil und
Strafprozessen wir werden uns das
sicherlich im Detail noch anschauen
müssen ob da die grundsätzlichen
Verfahrensgrundsätze ob die
Persönlichkeitsrechte der Beteiligten
gewahrt sind ob die Aufteilung zwischen
den Instanzen weiterhin gewahrt ist aber
das ganze wird ja nur funktionieren wenn
eben die Ausstattung der Gericht in der
Breite des Landes auch entsprechend ist
und deshalb mein Appell hier die Länder
noch mal deutlich zu unterstützen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben
hier oft Austausch mit rechts und
Rechtsanwälten und Notarin wenn wir
ehrlich sind aber diese Umsetzung der
Digitalisierung das braucht auch die
Mitwirkung der anderen justizberufe
deshalb möchte ich die auch hier heute
explizit erwähnen von den
gerichtsvollzieherinnen bis zu den
Rechtspflegern Urkundsbeamte der
Geschäftsstelle Justiz Sekretäre
notarassistente alle sie tragen ein ganz
essentiellen Beitrag bei zum
Funktionieren unserer Justiz und dazu
will ich heute auch mal explizit danke
sagen ich will aber nicht nur beim dank
stehen bleiben sondern auch Anliegen die
mehr aus dieser Seite auch angetragen
worden sind hier weitergeben
es gibt Anlass sich da noch mal
anzuschauen ob die Zuständigkeiten und
Kompetenzen richtig verteilt sind oder
ob da auch noch ungehobene Ressourcen
sind und den stark Grund der dort immer
wieder formuliert wird bei der
Ausbildung mehr zu tun das zu einem
Fachhochschulstudium zu machen finde ich
sollten wir auch schauen wie wir das
ermöglichen können
meine lieben Kollegen wir haben
Verantwortung für den rechts und auch
für die Durchsetzung des Rechtsstaats
und hier kommt mir die Innenministerin
gerade recht denn ich will sie loben und
ihnen danken dass sie den Kampf gegen
Cyberkriminalität so ernst nehmen wir
haben hier das geben die jährlichen
Berichte des Bundeskriminalamts einen
krassen aufwuchs von
Cyberkriminalität in all ihren Facetten
es werden Unternehmen kritische
Infrastruktur gehackt
erpresstörer sind Opfer von
Identitätsdiebstahl Hetze und
Beleidigungen das wurde schon erwähnt
organisierte Kriminalität bis hin zu
feindlichen Attacken und wir tun im
Kampf gegen Kindesmissbrauch und
missbrauchsdarstellungen im Internet
nicht alles was wir tun könnten wenn wir
auf naheliegende Ermittlungsansätze wie
retrogradig gespeicherte
IP-Adressen verzichten und zwar
natürlich
in dem Umfang wie es das
Bundesverfassungsgericht unter
Europäische Gerichtshof erlaubt haben
und da muss ich wirklich sagen dass der
Vergleich mit chinesischer
überwachungspolitik von Ihnen Herr
Minister wirklich komplett daneben ist
absurd ist die können Sie das
Vergleichen chinesische totale
Inhaltskontrolle personenbezogen versus
die Zuordnung von Zahlenkolonnen mit
denen für sich genommen keiner etwas
Ankern kann wie können Sie das
Vergleichen mit der dezentralen
Speicherung von Daten die da einfach
bleiben für eine Weile wo sie entstehen
dezentral bei den Providern im Vergleich
zu einer chinesischen Zusammenfassung
aller Daten
wie können Sie das Vergleichen wenn hier
der Zugriff auf diese Daten immer auf
die Richtervorbehalt abhängig ist was
halten sie eigentlich von ihren
ermitteln was erhalten halten sie von
den Richtern und ihrer Bindung an Gesetz
und Ordnung wenn Sie das Vergleichen das
frage ich mich wirklich
deshalb bleibt mir nicht mehr liegen
Winkel das geht jetzt nicht noch sagen
und ich danke Ihnen
Elisabeth winkelmeyer Bäcker war dass
die Vorsitzende im Rechtsausschuss des
Deutschen Bundestages wir sind bei der
dritt letzten Rednerin
angekommen und das ist Luisa liegt China
oder aus der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Minister
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren der
Einzelplan 07 für die Justiz mit einem
Gesamtvolumen von gut einer Milliarde
ist ein kleiner Haushalt aber für uns
JuristInnen die wir jedoch einige im
Bundestag sind ist es doch ein sehr
wichtiger Haushalt es ist der unserer
Demokratie und der Rechtsprechung wir
leben in fragilen Zeiten das ist schon
angesprochen worden und unser Haus der
Demokratie braucht feste Säulen schauen
wir in den Iran in die Türkei nach
Russland aber auch in andere Länder so
muss ich mich doch heute auch noch mal
fragen was ist das für ein Staat oder
was ist das für eine Justiz sie ist
zulässt das Frauen angeordnet angeordnet
vom Staat zusammengeprügelt werden
eingesperrt werden dass auf Kinder
geschossen wird das ist eine Stadt ist
absolut unwürdig und ja das muss auch an
dieser Stelle mal gesagt werden wo auch
unser Justizsystem heute so kritisiert
wird und sie dann noch mal zurückzuholen
wollen in die Realität was woanders wo
in dieser Welt auch gerade geschieht
während an meiner Tätigkeit als
entscheiderin beim Bundesamt für
Migration und Flüchtlinge habe ich viele
Asylverfahren und viele Menschen
angehört die von ihrem Staat verfolgt
wurden und wo die Justiz in der Heimat
zugeschaut hat oder sogar mitgemacht hat
in diesen Verfahren habe ich viel gehört
und Sie können sich gar nicht vorstellen
wie ohnmächtig oder hilflos man da steht
wenn man am Ende feststellen so muss
dass der eigene Staat ein verraten hat
und dass man hilflos vor ihm steht und
ihm nicht vertrauen kann
deshalb ist es gut und richtig dass wir
erstmals elil das sind nämlich die
europäischen loyers in Lesbos mit 75.000
Euro unterstützen das ist
was ist ein kleiner ein kleiner Beitrag
aber wichtig ist dass wir einsteigen und
wir werden oder sollten auch in Zukunft
zusehen dass wir unsere Initiative
diesbezüglich auch ausbauen elil
arbeitet seit 2016 und war ursprünglich
eine Initiative des deutschen
anwaltsvereins und der europäischen
anwaltsvereinigung in Kooperation mit
den griechischen Anwaltskammern als
unabhängige Rechtsberatung für
geflüchtete an den EU-Außengrenzen
bieten ehrenamtlich arbeitende
Rechtsanwältin mit
Sachkunde auf dem Gebiet des Rechts das
Asylrecht seine individuelle und
kostenlose und Studenten finanzierte
Rechtsberatung so dass die Unterstützung
die wir jetzt im Haushalt da
bereitgestellt haben auf jeden Fall ein
guter Weg ist
dass ein Staat seine Staatsbürgerin
rechtlos stellt das ist bei uns
undenkbar wir alle sollten dankbar dafür
sein dass wir in dieser funktionierenden
Demokratie leben dürfen und nicht auf
der Demokratie auf dem Rücken der
Demokratie unsere Spielchen spielen von
den sieben Millionen Euro die wir im
Haushalt für die Stiftung für
internationale rechtliche Zusammenarbeit
bereitstellen haben wir 500.000 Euro für
die Ukraine vorgesehen die iaz
unterstützt den EU-Beitritt der Ukraine
und die notwendigen rechtlichen
justiziellen Reformvorhaben auch das ist
in angesichts unserer der geopolitischen
Lage genau der richtige weggehen da die
Stiftung geht unser Justizsystem hat
aber auch Vorbildcharakter auch wenn man
heute meint man müsste diese Dinge
kritisieren aber die deutlich Justiz ist
in Europa und weltweit anerkannt in
allen allen die Justizwesen muss ich
daher auch noch mal heute an dieser
Stelle auf unseren Dank aussprechen ich
möchte noch mal auf den EU-Kommissar die
die rheinlast zu sprechen kommen der
zuletzt den Jahresbericht der
Europäischen Kommission vorgestellt hat
und da das deutsche Justizsystem auch
noch mal als besonders unabhängig gelobt
hat und auch in dem Zusammenhang eben
auch gelobt hat dass wir den Pakt für
den Rechtsstaat jetzt weiter ausbauen
und dass wir da noch mal 200 Millionen
Euro quasi im Haushalt aufgesattelt
haben das ist genau der richtige Weg und
damit bringen wir auch die justizdigital
auf die Höhe der Zeit
wir müssen einfach damit anfangen
nach unserem Produktionsvertrag wollen
wir aber auch berichtsverfahren
schneller und effizienter machen dazu
werden wir zeitnah die EU
verbandsklagenrichtlinie umsetzen das
ist mir auch ein persönlich ein sehr
wichtiges Anliegen weil da auch die
Justiz entlastet wird und wir zahlreiche
individualklagen vermeiden können in dem
kollektivverbraucherverbände ihre Rechte
am Ende einklagen und in Diensten
Zusammenhang und auch zu dieser
Jahreszeit kurz vor Weihnachten wünsche
ich mir natürlich auch noch was
persönlich vielleicht auch was wir hier
als Bundesgesetzgeber umsetzen können
nämlich dass wir mal die Chance
ergreifen kollektivrechte weil noch mal
zu Ende zu denken und kollektive
Verbandsklagen und da gibt es die
tierschutzrechtliche Verbandsklage die
ich gerne auf Bundesebene auch mal
regeln würde und genauso eben auch ein
Verbandsklagerecht für Gewerkschaften
was am Ende eben auch dazu führt dass
ArbeitnehmerInnen VerbraucherInnen auch
bei der Rechtssetzung in kollektiven
Verfahren gleich vorgestellt würden und
das am Ende auch unsere Justiz und auch
die Länder entlastet
[Applaus]
im Zuge des Verbraucherschutzes
die Stiftung mit einer Million für
Datenschutz war auch wichtig die hilft
vielen Vereinen in Deutschland sich zu
informieren und den Anbetracht des
Volumens haben wir doch ganz schön viele
Projekte auf den Weg gebracht vielen
Dank
man kann es ja mal versuchen in diesem
Fall Luisa liegt China Bode in der
Debatte zum des Bundesjustizminister und
gleich nach der nächsten nach dem
nächsten Redner geht es weiter mit dem
Etat der bundesinnenministerin gestern
noch in Katar gestern noch mit einem
deutlichen Zeichen mit der berühmten
inzwischen berühmten One Love Binde auf
der Ehrentribüne beim Fußballspiel der
deutschen Nationalmannschaft heute wie
gesagt schon wieder zurück im Parlament
und wie gesagt gleich geht es auch um
ihren Etat wir hören aber vorher noch
Lukas Benner aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen
[Applaus]
genehmigungsbeschleunigung geht wer
alles beschleunigen will beschleunigen
kurzfristig gar nichts und deswegen
brauchen wir einen klaren Vorgang für
klimafreundliche Infrastruktur denn es
kann doch nicht unser Ziel sein dass wir
auf neu gebaut noch breiteren Autobahnen
ohne Tempolimit zurück ins 19
Jahrhundert fahren nein wir brauchen die
Infrastruktur für die ökologische
Transformation wir brauchen den Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren Energie
und lassen Sie mich noch mit einem
vermeintlichen Widerspruch aufräumen es
ist nicht Klimakrise gegen atemkrise es
ist nicht der Widerspruch von Natur und
Umweltschutz gegen Infrastruktur sondern
wir müssen das zusammendenken wir müssen
die Krisen dieser Zeit zusammenbringen
und nur so können wir gemeinsam
vorangehen und die Probleme lösen die
hier vor uns stehen denn nicht
Feldhamster und roten Milan sind das
Problem in unserem Land nicht
Feldhamster und Rotmilan blockieren und
verlangsamen die Verfahren sondern es
ist die mangelnde Digitalisierung
mangelndes Personal und langwierige
Verfahren und deswegen ist es so gut
dass wir hier gemeinsam vorangehen und
Herr Dr lieb Herr Buschmann sie haben es
gesagt ich freue mich auf die
parlamentarischen Beratung zur VWG UNO
Welle 80C Absatz 2 und der
Anwendungsbereich wir haben dann noch
was zu klären aber gemeinsam gehen wir
hier den richtigen Weg
auch im Haushalt finden wir hier die
ersten Ansätze der neuer Senat am
Bundesverwaltungsgericht die Mittel für
Digitalisierung das sind genau die
Schritte die wir brauchen so gehen wir
voran so zeigen wir was möglich ist und
so meinen wir ernst was wir in den
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben haben
Planungs- und genehmigungsbeschleunigung
wird es mit uns geben wir arbeiten daran
und bei allen kleinen Differenzen die
wir vielleicht noch haben wir gehen
gemeinsam nach vorne denn wir wollen ein
Recht auf Höhe der Zeit und ich bin mir
so sicher wie noch nie dass wir das
gemeinsam hinbekommen vielen Dank
Respekt
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den Einzelplan 07
Bundesministerium der Justiz in der
ausschussfassung
wer stimmt dafür
Dankeschön wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich niemand der
Einzelplan 07 ist mit den Stimmen der
Koalitionsfraktionen gegen die Stimmen
der
Oppositionsfraktionen angenommen
Abstimmung über den Einzelplan 19
Bundesverfassungsgericht in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür
danke wer stimmt dagegen wer enthält
sich der Einzelplan 19 ist einstimmig
angenommen